[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up stick to football taking over
bleach report today yeah we got Melo in
the chair now Connor riding alongside
guys we're gonna break down every pic of
Round four and five in a very
conversational type of way but we're
actually going to guess what talk about
the players pick today everyone else
they're gonna be talk about Kyler Marie
or drew Locke crying on camera we are
going to talk about these players that
will make your football team better guys
want another booth Saturday morning this
is fun yeah nice stick to fellas a
better day it kind of has a nice ring to
it we might have to start putting
another one out there I don't know about
that I got plenty of good players on the
board still here especially at wide
receiver today so the top around four is
gonna be really exciting I think we're
gonna see a lot of trades and here we go
this is what's left of my big board
Chauncey Gardiner Johnson a very bizarre
slide Matt you know alluded to it last
night maybe some poor interviews there
that are causing this drop Kelvin Harmon
you see from that wide receiver group
there Hakeem Butler the big wide
receiver out of Iowa State and Riley
Ridley from Georgia so if your team
needs a skilled player or a safety
you're still looking pretty good in this
group right now yeah we've got the
Arizona Cardinals will come up on the
clock to restart here here's my big
board again Chauncey Gartner Johnson
were surprised by the drop interviews a
big part there but as Connor said
there's still good value here in melo at
number 62 i know you're a big fan of
Jarrett's didn't all burn
i can't wait to see what jarrett Statham
does where he goes today I think he's
gonna be a good fit this was my number
one quarterback coming into this draft I
won't hide from it I'm not ashamed I
think he has a lot of talent a lot of
skill there and he's gonna be very happy
he's gonna make some team very happy
whenever he gets drafted Melo you'll
like hearing this once he might heard
that has done a ton of work on Jarrett
situm really likes his arm and overall
talent and feels they could develop him
is the New England
so they got your guy Nikhil Harry in
round one they did themselves a lot of
favors yesterday with plenty of good
picks keep an eye on the Patriots and
Jared Stidham today if they draft Jared
Stidham and Foster Monroe and Nikhil
Harry sorry Pat mahomes I might have to
change my favor you the next Miller
that's the page I'm not like that I can
do it I'm just I'm it feels good to win
guys I was gonna tell you it feels real
good to win so we got the Cardinals on
the clock the San Francisco 49ers then
Connors New York Jets
the Oakland Raiders and the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers are the top five teams today
coming off the board and there is guys
there is Talent this is where you can
get a player that maybe fell due to
injury may be due to character and I
think that's where we saw the top of
those boards guys like Hakeem Butler
Kelvin a Harmon not falling for injury
not falling for character but falling
because NFL teams want I think a more
diverse route tree if there's a lesson
to be learned from this 2019 draft so
far Deacon Metcalfe falls to the end of
round two now these two big receivers
are gonna fall and I think that says if
you're a college wide receiver right now
you want to think about trying to run
some extra routes this summer because
you're gonna need to show more than a
three route route tree to get drafted
early and I think it goes back to once
again you know some of the guys here
that are the bigger wide receivers in
this group it didn't run well I know who
Kean Butler surprised a lot of people
with this 40 time at Indy but still a
lot of scouts feel that on the field
play speed the step slow I still love
his ability in the red zone love his
ability after the catch and same gonna
be said for Calvin Harmon that's one of
my favorite wide receivers in this class
I think there are some overall top-end
speed questions there but if you need
possession guys these are two of the
better ones in this group yeah and the
consistency comes into play especially
when you talk about Butler we talked
about him before he can make some
circus-style catches it's those easy
consistent catches that are the drought
problems for him and then FL teams they
like the guys that can move in shake and
you see the guys on the big board here
with Matt I think all of these guys have
problems with that they're not the
quickest guy they're not the three cone
stars they have trouble separating in
college and they might have that problem
in the NFL to a lot of upside with
Hakeem Butler though you get in the red
zone just put him on the field the guy
could make a play you know legit
six-foot-five which a lot of guys say
they're six foot five like I say I'm 511
he's actually six foot five but he is a
big target with with speed Riley
Ridley's interesting his brother Calvin
Ridley drafted in the first round busy
the Atlanta Falcons last year I actually
think he's had a bit of a fall here of
the guys who are actually good route
runners that are left on the board he is
one of those players so they're about to
go on the clock
officially the Arizona Cardinals the
picks are gonna come off fast and
furious today we are going to do our
best to keep up talked about each pick
there will be times where we have to
bump out grade some picks you guys will
see those videos as we make them you'll
get
grades from the three of us most likely
on some of the quarterbacks today guys
Jack Stidham is still out there
Tyree Jackson is available Ryan Finley
is available so we could see a little
bit of a run on quarterbacks today guys
that might be developmental type players
that they you don't have the biggest
starting up side but my guy gardner
minshew i can't wait to see where he
lands if he let him he lands the bus -
the jorts
he has swag down he's got to get picked
wait when did this happen
when did he become your guy I'm talking
to you for roughly 31 years talk about
Gardner Minshew until this weekend what
is it about his game other than the
jorts so I do love the jorts and the
mustache because that takes confidence
it's like what a baseball player has an
ugly girlfriend he's not even confident
in the batter's box if you can rock a
mustache in jorts
you're a confident quarterback I also
like that he went from East Carolina and
no one wanted him I don't care what Bama
fans say you guys offered him a coaching
scholarship and he goes to Washington
State wins the starting job and becomes
a very productive prolific passer so no
he's not gonna be a starter in the NFL
but if I were a team that needed a
really good backup quarterback Gardner
Minshew is gonna be a pick for me I mean
I go back to that quarterback graphic
and I think the guy for me that stands
out purely on a trade spaces that you
stache and develop his Tyree Jackson I
absolutely
he love the size you love the speed that
kind of profile is comparable to Cam
Newton but he's got to get more accurate
it's as simple as that and he spent a
lot of time training alongside guru Lak
and Jarrett said I'm under Jordan Palmer
that's a really good place to be for him
to work on those mechanics to work on
that after seeing this guy he's a
football junkie so I think wherever he
lands it'll be really nice value on day
three where you probably won't have to
see the field any time this year and
that's okay but he is the talent or at
least the traits to mold into a future
starter yeah if you guys have questions
for the crew today
send them in hashtag be our draft our
guys in the control room we'll get them
up for us right here on the screen so we
do want to answer your questions
especially as we're waiting the Arizona
Cardinals have about four minutes left
to make this pick guys they've had an
interesting draft they've basically
drafted the shortest player at every
position but they've also added a lot of
speed tyler murray is now there byron
murphy a corner you add in Andy Isabella
Zach Allen these are big names that
we've talked about a lot over the past
several months be interesting to see if
where they go here because I do feel
like they still have some needs that
could be addressed and we
thing about round four is not often
about need because you don't expect
these guys to be starters but remember
Richard Sherman kam chancellor Grady
Jarrett some really good players were
found in on day three that became
starters yeah I mean in the goat Tom
Brady yeah he was he's an outlier I
didn't like to throw his name in there
he doesn't count that's not fair it's
day three of the draft Matt you have to
mention Tom Brady he should know this as
a patriot family and you look at that
Arizona draft I mean they got some of my
favorite players in terms of great value
I love Byron Murphy I thought he was the
best corner in this draft I thought Zach
Allen is the day one starter tons of
production in the ACC while Austin
College high character player football
junkie Andy Isabella it was a little
early for me but we know this offense
with Kliff Kingsbury wants speed and
with that guy Kyler Murray under center
now or probably in shotgun he's gonna be
airing it down yeah I don't think he's
gonna get under center a whole lot I
mean he wouldn't have a problem with it
though right yeah get all the way under
the center we got a question from @j
crumby which wide receivers left on day
three have the best chance to become
stars in the NFL I think the obvious
answer is gonna be Hakeem Butler from
Iowa State if he can get in the right
situation I think like Melo said where
you just throw the ball to him in the
red zone let him be a jump ball receiver
he could have a lot of success yeah and
I think going back to the wide receivers
we showed earlier we saw a lot of teams
reach on speed yesterday but there's
still some vertical targets there that
were underutilized in college Emanuel
Hall at Missouri Darius Leighton from
Auburn so it's an exciting group there
you know those guys didn't get the
targets and the quarterback helped at
times all the time I know Paul played
with Locke yes still it's gonna be
interesting to see when we got the pick
guys it is so keen Butler says I finally
go with a height weight speed prospect
we're gonna grade this pick so guys get
your grades ready the key Butler at one
time and there are still people out
there who have a day one grade on this
player so the a little bit of a surprise
to see him fall to pick 103 but he is
very very talented and will jump into it
let's go here guys Akeem Butler to the
Arizona Cardinals giving Kyler Murray
that big threat down the field
six-foot-five for four speed guys and I
think what's the best player available
headed into day three Connor your
thoughts on Hakeem Butler I absolutely
love this pick we saw them do yesterday
they got Byron Murphy the best player
available now they start day three with
the best player available Hakim Butler
you want to talk about
sighs in the redzone the ability to make
things happen after the catch he's got
to work on his routes a little bit but
you see the pure physicality that's just
winning the football over the defender
and guess what get off me I'm bigger
than you
I love his ability to get into the end
zone time and time again and he's a
quarterbacks best friend we're gonna see
Kyler Murray run around extend plays
scheme Butler work back to the football
and I mean come on that's great
athleticism at that size that's rare 6 5
is written he's really built more like a
lanky kind of tight end but he's gonna
play wide receiver in this offense so I
look at this pick in this situation and
that offense under Kliff Kingsbury this
is simply an a for me I absolutely love
it
Melo yeah and I'm gonna agree with you
Connor I'm gonna go Eddie this is round
four and you're getting some people's
number one receiver here you have a
young quarterback go get him a big
target and you got one of the biggest at
receiver this year he can go make crazy
catches he might need to with Kyler wary
starting as a rookie
yeah Larry Fitzgerald getting older
we'll see what the future is there guys
I'm actually gonna give this an A+ and I
huh
the host gets to do grades on day three
I again the value here is amazing he is
an athlete and I think Kliff Kingsbury
we're gonna see a lot of four in five
wide receiver sets the key butler's
gonna get on the field very very early
for the Arizona Cardinals all right you
guys have officially done a great video
I'm proud of you officially impersonated
left gopher did you like that yeah yeah
I'm gonna do the Russell Wilson boys
real well the Bengals are trading up
guys to pick number two in this draft
with the San Francisco 49ers and again
there's still talent on the board the
Bengals could maybe go with one of those
safeties here Chauncey Gardiner Johnston
Jonte Thompson I have liked Jonah
Williams I did not like what they did
after it I think the Bengals have had a
little bit of a mixed bag in this year's
draft class do we see them maybe go
Jared Stidham get a quarterback behind
Andy Dalton maybe that's why you're
trading up to get one of those top
quarterbacks yeah and that is actually a
comp that I had made I think that
Statham is kind of that Andy Dalton guy
here in round four like are you kidding
me he can be a huge upside for a team
that doesn't know what they have at the
future at quarterback
so if Statham can come in and do it just
enough learn the offense this year part
ways with Andy Dalton you're all set for
your future in my opinion yeah I'm
curious to see why they moved up here I
still think there's you know some day to
even they want Talent with Chauncey
Gardiner Johnson like you said
year but this pic to me you would think
it would be offense they already took
your main Pratt linebacker we really
liked so I think they stay away from
that position group and I mean Calvin
Harmons on the board
AJ greens been banged up they still
could use some help at wide receiver
John Ross was not the guy they thought
they were getting so don't roll that out
either I like Tyler Boyd I think he has
some potential there as a number two
receiver but again yeah this is a team
that they went oh line
I got a linebacker lady said Jermaine
Pratt a player that we all really liked
but they still have a lot of needs as
Cincinnati Bengals do so this trade
basically swapped fourth round picks and
the Niners get to sixth round picks in
this year's draft in order to make this
trade so the Niners move back get some
draft capital that they actually needed
they were short on picks in this year's
draft and the pig guys it is a
quarterback
it is not Jairus Didem is not Tyree
Jackson it is on Ryan Finley so with
Ryan Finley honestly I know that you
guys might not like him as much as I do
but he can come in and learn that often
see us Tazewell I think he's probably a
career backup maybe a guy that can come
in and steal some starts for any dalton
when he gets hurt so I I kind of like
this pick we're gonna grate it boys
because it's a quarterback and we have
to talk about it the Cincinnati Bengals
trade up in round four guys and it is
for a quarterback this guy Ryan Finley a
player at one point in time talked about
is a first-round pick coming out of NC
State tall quarterback accurate
quarterback the arm strength I'm anxious
to see what you guys think I mean I
don't dislike the pick of this point of
the draft I think he fits with what Zack
Taylor obviously wants to do there in
terms of short and intermediate accuracy
that's really the name of the game here
for Ryan Finley and you'll see it the
touch on the throws that's the most
amend Kelvin Harmon helping him out a
little bit Khan over the defender but I
mean Ryan family had a lot of production
in college and he's a really really
smart guy so you could see the fit here
with a young head coach he's not gonna
come in and be expected to start right
away they have Andy Dalton there I think
it's a really good future as a long-term
backup a guy that can come in and
control the game but not necessarily win
you in the game and I think at the top
around four that's okay so I look at
this pick there was still some more
talented quarterbacks on the board Melos
guy Jarrett's sidam Tyree Jackson I'll
give it a b-minus cuz I like the fit and
I'm right there with you Connor I'm
gonna give this one a b-plus though I do
like to fit you don't know what you have
with Andy Dalton going forward so if you
want to go get it quarter
I like Brian Finley I think he's a guy
that can come in the game not make a lot
of mistakes for you just come in learn
the offense do some things and then
maybe take over for Andy Dalton next
year oh you think it's like a poor match
Jared Goff is that what's happening he
kind of looks like Jared go up there
built a seven-way I'm gonna better be -
I agree with Connor there were two
better quarterbacks on the board in my
opinion with Jared Stidham with Tyree
Jackson but I think from a scheme fit
for what Zach Taylor wants to do it does
make some sense that Ryan Finley's to
pick here dude with some upside so we'll
see if he can work out for the
Cincinnati Bengals long term alright
guys and now we have another trade your
Jets were on the clock Connor the Saints
trade up to this spot and again we're
seeing teams leapfrog because there is
good value on the board we see this
happen every year on day three teams go
home they reassess the value overnight
on Friday and then we'll see some
activity here yeah I'm curious to see
the terms of this deal because I you
know had found out last night the Jets
after trading their fifth round pick for
Colette Jo Semele we're looking to get
some more pics on day three at the top
of these you know first two rounds here
with the third overall pick on day three
they knew they had a chance to move that
so it looks like the Saints will now be
picking in that spot we'll keep you
updated on that return super important
because the Jets did have only two picks
yeah under and a sixth round that's not
my fifth thinnest sixth was all they had
so this will help getting these these
extra picks we'll find out what that is
and the pick is in for the Saints so
we'll know that one shortly the Saints
have had a quiet draft they take Eric
McCoy who's going to come in I think has
to be penciled in as a day one starter
the Jets Connor get a fourth and a fifth
round pick there you go back here so
they get a little more draft capital
they'll have four picks as of now on day
three yep that they can help add some
talent to this team that 168 well then
the extra pick they add 168 there it is
so they've had an interesting draft the
Saints though Eric McCoy there was talk
that they might have actually been
involved a little bit with some talk for
wide receiver so I would keep an eye on
someone they want to get another
receiver in this offense running back
could also be a need justice Hill is
still out there so they I think offense
I know there's a team that like you
think of Drew Brees and Michael Thomas
in Alvin Kamara like why would they go
offense but they want to continue to add
depth offensively I think for me I mean
Kelvin Harmon is sitting right there
he's a seamless fit in this offense so
I'm very excited to see what the Saints
do here yeah and I think that it could
even be running back I know
that they lost Mark Ingram they have a
very good running back but you still
need depth of that position because we
haven't seen Alvin Kamara be the number
one guy that go-to guy that can carry
the ball you know 20 times a game and
catch it five so if they went running
back here I wouldn't be surprised I
think it's just very like Sean Payton to
go offense like they will probably
address it somewhere even tight in
running back or receiver here yeah it
will be interesting to see what the
Saints do because again I think a lot of
people think that you would think
defense eye safety you know they could
use depth on the defensive line but we
all seem to think offense is the best
fit and I think some too because the
offensive players have fallen down the
board so there are there are good
players that are out there right now but
if they were one of those safeties I
think we would all applaud that pick
like Chauncey Gardiner Johnson is a
future starter in the NFL and all of our
opinions no matter what happened with
the team interviews I think the football
play is actually really really good back
there jeyonce Thompson is a free safety
prospect at Alabama maybe a guy who came
out a little early Mack Wilson is still
on the board a linebacker so there's
there's still some good like starting
caliber talent and not guys that you
have like manufacturer hype about and
these are really good players that are
still there yeah I agree with you
completely
Deonte Thompson could be a fit there I'm
eager to see what they do with this pick
they could go in any direction really
yeah and Teddy Bridgewater is the
quarterback of the future with Drew
Brees we'll see how much longer he has
so maybe not a quarterback here because
they like their boy Teddy and we're
getting a little ridiculous with these
announcements here I mean we got like 20
people how the podium right now these
three people all day announcing the
picks to you yeah it's you know they try
to make everything in a vent suite
there's still time we could get the
production team to round five bring them
in
yeah round five will announce the picks
that way they're taking their sweet time
makes the pick the Saints are and once
we know that we'll relay it to you guys
guys I just saw this come across Nick
Saban now at Alabama has had 29
first-round picks that actually seems
low to me yeah yeah I would have went
one more I would have I mean every year
though it all right guys the pick is in
and it is Chauncey Gardiner Johnson so
teams are just attacking our big board
this morning taking the best players
available and actually
king of my dock he was the top-rated
player still on my heart too by far yeah
39 overall could play as a slot corner
type I really like Chauncey Gardiner
Johnson's ability and Connor I know you
were super high on him I really was I
just think it's versatility and coverage
is phenomenal item 26 so we're gonna
grade this pick yes I'm fun yeah we are
gonna have some fun here the Saints a
small draft but so far a pretty impaired
one one yeah yeah right Adam left go the
New Orleans Saints trade up to get the
best player available Chauncey Gardiner
Johnson from Florida ball skills a
tackler really a Swiss Army knife on
defense guys Connor what do you think of
this pick NZ this player I absolutely
love this pick and I love this player
and I know there was some current the
concerns you said with how he
interviewed but this is incredible value
at this point when you look at the
player what he can do in coverage he can
play as a big nickel he can play as I
think he didn't play single high safety
but he got a lot better doing this
coming downhill stopping screens
stopping the run that's something he
didn't do as a sophomore got much better
at it as a junior so this is phenomenal
value and I think for this secondary
this is a player that will be on the
field at least in nickle situations
right away ball skills instincts the guy
is an absolute playmaker and a very very
good athlete so once again I mean that's
why they traded up with the Jets to go
get this guy this is an A+ pick all the
way for me I mean you see it right there
448 speed the vertical it's very simple
for me this is the best pick of the day
by far and probably will be the best
pick of the day
yeah I'm right there with you a plus
plus if I could go that way if you have
a need and your secondary he can fill it
I think he could even come in and
develop as a guy who can play on the
outside it corner he's definitely gonna
be able to play nickel he can play in
the box safety he could probably play
single hide to Sean Payton sees this guy
and says we'll find a place for him on
the defense he can make things happen
very good pick for this we thought the
Saints might go offense guys they went
best player available on defense and for
that you get an A+ the rich just get
richer this is a team that they're gonna
make a run in the NFC I know that's not
like the hottest takeover but surprise
of the Saints from the Super Bowl next
year because he won't miss and tackle in
the open field like some other players
there's it probably just jinxed that one
probably did yeah now he's gonna duck
his head the Raiders are on the clock
the pick is in will have that shortly
the Raiders draft so far guys to recap
it has been
big school all power 5 schools basically
Cleveland furrow from Clemson Josh Jacob
from Alabama Jonathan Abram from
Mississippi State in the Trayvon Mullin
from Clemson so basically if you made
the college football playoff Jon Jon
Gruden mike Mayock have evaluated your
tape and this might be a little early in
some eyes but I know this is one of
those teams that could be looking at
foster Muro as well he definitely fits
the mold of the type of player John drew
in the Blitz but it's rather drum the
SEC that would not surprise me here I'm
excited to see what they do so and
Anthony Nelson from Iowa would be
another guy up front for that defensive
line I can see on day three yeah not
Foster Marrero he's not a fit for what
the Raiders want to do he doesn't need
to be in the AFC West I don't I don't
like that four across you I'm just gonna
have to disagree top I have to leave I'm
gonna have to take a bath we understand
that that is mellows guy and Foster
Moreau should hear his name called at
some point here on day three McManus
yep and it is guys max Crosby edge
rusher okay not a big school player no
but fun one but in a really good tester
as well coming out of Eastern Michigan I
compared him to Jeremiah attached you
guys we're just gonna talk amongst us
here but 466 speed and someone who
wouldn't you look at like the short
shuttle he ran a four one three short
shuttle
I didn't say oh my goodness like this
guy can actually get after a little bit
kind of a workout warrior small level of
competition but they go back to the edge
where they went with four overall now
you have someone that can maybe be a
rotational that pass rusher when you
have Cleveland fertile and orden key
you've got two super long guys now you
add in Crosby who's six foot five 255
pounds yeah and you look if you're
looking for a wide nine kind of rusher I
mean this is your guy and you saw it on
tape with him I know he played against a
lower level of competition but he has
the ability to bend dip turn around the
corner and he's explosive off the snap
and we saw that with his testing time so
the Raiders here looking for a diamond
in the rough pass rusher on day three
this was one of the guys I had marked
down as a guy worth taking you know the
dice roll on here yeah you already have
Cleveland for all I think he we talked
about him as the guy who's a very low
floor like you know what you're getting
out of Cleveland furl
so you can take a chance here with max
Crosby who might be more of a
developmental guy but you don't need to
play him immediately you might get some
you might get some boom out of
this round pick round for pick I like it
for the Raiders even though they already
addressed that edge position I actually
had him ranked much later than this I do
like to fit and I like that he's not
gonna be prep like brought in and
immediately asked to be a contributor
like maybe he is a nickel pass rusher or
someone that can be you know a third
down player that comes into place like
15 20 percent year snaps could play
special teams our guy Jake Romney we had
another question which team would be the
best landing spot on day three for Tyree
Jackson in terms of overall development
and possible future success I'm actually
going to say is the team that's on the
clock right now the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
put him in Bruce Arians offense where
everything's down the field that's what
he does best
yeah accuracy was a problem for him let
him sit for a year behind Jameis Winston
let him learn a little bit of how the
NFL works and continue to work on
I wrote a profile on this guy he didn't
have a quarterback coach in high school
like all these other kids do he was
watching YouTube cut up Tom Brady going
in the back yard and throwing through a
tire hanging from a tree like that's how
he learned how to play quarterback so he
is still developmentally very role yeah
and when he was walking through this
office he saw one of the pictures here
of Tom Brady and he just stopped gasps I
mean that's his guy he's obsessed with
football he's a football junkie he knows
everything about the game lives the game
so I look at Tyree Jackson and I really
like that fit mat for the you know terms
of coaching another fit for me would be
the Chiefs because I think he does a lot
of things best that they do in their
offense Pittsburgh Steelers another fit
for him there so yeah Carolina would
have been a nice fit they got their
backup quarterback yesterday warrior
yeah I mean watch this dude's spin the
ball when we watched him at the Senior
Bowl it's like who he can launch the
ball down the field actually talked to
our friends at EA Sports with Madden
they said that he will have the second
strongest arm in the game when he's
drafted the he had they say he has a
stronger arm the Patrick mahomes so it's
Josh Allen him mahomes in terms of arm
strength yeah and that goes back to what
Conor was saying with the Chiefs if you
want to talk about best landing spots
for him as a player I'd want to be with
Andy Reid sorry Mel ten Bay Buccaneers
have taken Anthony Nelson a big
defensive end from Iowa Simon a great
way all along the defensive line Conor
you know that defense really really well
Todd Bowles is the defensive coordinator
there they're probably gonna run a lot
of base three for Anthony Nelson would
seem to fit that as a versatile piece up
front yeah
sot volts really likes the big edge
defenders that can you know contain set
the edge but he has more pass-rush
ability than giving credit for so I
think this is incredible value here I'll
say that right off the top I had him
sixty eighth overall max Crosby who went
a couple picks before this I mean he was
160 for me and I liked both players but
Anthony Nelson is one of my red star
guys the guy that you can plug and play
and rely on so this is a phenomenal
phenomenal value pick hey guys the New
York Giants were on the clock next they
made their pick and we are going to
grade it is Julian love the corner all
done oder dame so we're gonna talk about
Julian love a golden dome or maybe it's
a big tape yeah they've added two really
good corners now the New York Giants
continue to add to the defensive
backfield DeAndre Baker 1st now they add
Julian love big time players from big
time programs a guy that I believe would
be a second round pick maybe a third
rounder in a worst case scenario he
comes up to board around for Conor how
great is this value the phenomenal value
Julian Love was one of my favorite
corners in this draft when you go down
the list he was my sixth ranked corner
only a couple spots behind the entree
Baker a guy they traded into the first
round to get you see it the clickin
closed downhill he's got ball skills
he's a good tackler he plays with a
different energy this is the kind of
player that New York Giants defense
needed on the back end so I look at this
this is simply an A+ pick for the g-men
yeah and I'm gonna go up pretty similar
to you again here at Conner I think we
just been talking too much I really like
Julian Love I thought he was a guy that
could go second round so to pick him up
in the fourth round way to go Dave
gentlemen maybe this guy can draft and
he knows what he's doing here he loves
corners about that now he loves corners
what's interesting guys he got a second
round grape from the NFL draft Advisory
Committee well not a good look for them
I'm gonna give it an A+ I think he can
work his way into a starting corner
position we'll see how long generous
Jenkins is there there's been some talk
about maybe he could be on the move so a
plus for me Dave gentlemen I know we
aren't friends but you're redeeming
yourself a little bit here on day three
of the draft Julian love to the New York
Giants
alright guys an Indianapolis Colts are
on the clock we'll see if they actually
pick something they haven't done a lot
of traded out almost every time they've
been on the clock Chris Ballard likes
picks I am seeing that they traded up
for this so I guess they've been
triggered
twice now who's originally Jacksonville
two
Oakland now to Indy so maybe Indy trade
it up just a trade down again we'll see
that respect maybe Oakland Jacksonville
back to Oakland time boys is a flat sir
I would have say this before the pick is
in because we don't know if Ballard's
trading up for a guy it's an A+ pick
like for him to trade up in the draft
it's probably gonna be an all-pro the
rookie starter all-pro I don't know who
it is it could be a quarterback don't
buy taking offense I'm mad about Angela
yeah for Ballard idea guy and say oh we
have to go get you that is a great point
Melo that if you if you're on Ballard
radar EV we come on we got to go get him
or ed Dodds it's probably literally
punching the table right now telling
people to go up there and get this
player so there is actually a trade guys
the San Francisco 49ers have traded
linebacker Dakota Watson and a sixth
round pick to the Denver Broncos for a
fifth round pick
there's pick number 148 that's according
to Adam Schefter so the 49ers starting
to clean out a little bit I think
wouldn't be surprised if we see Solomon
Thomas moved this weekend as well as
they kind of reshuffle that defense a
little bit yeah I think this is why you
see the Colts go get so many picks
because on day three they like to move
around the board and they they feel like
they can great players better than
anyone in football and when those
players fall in day three they will come
up and get them so now you're seeing the
ballard effect really come into full
circle here on day three yeah and the
colts have had again a very very limited
draft so far they've made four picks
rocky said bin bon ago paris campbell
and bobby o curry key four players that
are going to be contributors if not
starters very very early for this team
there aren't a lot of needs left running
back is an area we were talking about
this last night mellow running back is
something to actually sniffed around a
decent amount on justice Hill is out
there Rodney Anderson is still out there
Bryce love from Stanford is thought
there so there are some running backs
who would be a good fit if they wanted a
backup for Marlin Mack yeah and I like
to high like Mike Weber
I don't know high o state a guy that
I've really liked for a couple years now
we always kind of look forward to the
next draft and who's coming up in that I
really like what he can do I know he was
a tandem back there at Ohio State with
Dobbins he's a guy that can carry the
load for you and if something happens to
Mack or you know he suffers an injury
you have a very quality started that can
come in and Mike Webber yeah and he yeah
injuries a lot in 2017 kind of got
bounced from the job once
JK Dobbins came
but I thought we ever had a good
bounce-back this year would definitely
be a fit for what the Colts have done
we've seen them really attacked the
edges so far wide receiver corner
getting an edge rusher a very rangy
linebacker so we haven't seen them go up
front though and I think that is a
ballard staple a lot of times as a line
trenches think about last year Quentin
Nelson
they also draft Braden Smith both guys
become very high-level starters when
Quinn Nelson was an all-pro and was
literally destroying people anytime he
pulled in trap so we'll see what the
Colts do no Pat McAfee announcing this
pick unfortunately no but it's still
taking just as long as pack if he took
so yeah they get their five minutes guys
they take their five minutes you only
get on TV every now and then and it
actually is a safety guy you mean Corey
Willis from Michigan State
I actually saw our good buddy Mel Kiper
had this is his second overall player
available today and sure someone that I
was not quite as high on I thought he
was more of a late-day three pick coming
out of Michigan State but a tester four
or five to a strong safety at 511 213
pounds someone who can come down in the
box maybe play next to Malik Hooker
maybe also be a special teams type
player yeah I think we look at this pick
and this is one of those safeties that
will be a sub package kind of player and
like you said there is a complementary
you know fit here next to Malik hooker
because he's not gonna be a guy that I
think you want playing single high
playing over the top of ton I think like
you said mat the testing time this is
probably what pushed him here because I
look at my safety board right now did
you think he would go before Deonte oh
no I mean even Imani home on Johnson
there's a lot of good safeties left here
so not that I dislike the pick but to
see them go up for him they know
something that well I know you watched a
ton of Justin Lane did Corey Willis pop
for you at all when you're watching that
honestly no but I'm gonna go with what I
said I'm gonna trust the Colts draft and
if they think that they can come in here
people didn't like that linebacker
drafted last year I don't remember how
it wasn't yeah he did he was an all-pro
that's right so I'm not gonna question
anything they do if they think that he
can be a fit as an in the Box safety
then go for it I love it I'm not gonna
question it yeah and and again I had
around 6th grade on him
in my notes the biggest thing for Carl
Willis was the coaches they're praised
his character his work ethic team leader
like just like a selfless guy so they
really liked his
they're topping speed was probably my
biggest concern when he was was asked to
turn a run over the top but they're not
gonna ask him to do that he's gonna play
in the box he's probably gonna play on
special teams and and the cloaks do a
great job of building for depth yeah you
look at the safety available he wouldn't
have been on this list guys yeah I mean
yeah it's interesting if they wanted
somebody that can come down hill well
mine who Kerr played a big nickel role
so that would've interestings your Quan
Johnson I know there's some size
concerns there but he's a physical
player and a lot of cover guys here you
go back to Deonte Thompson say Quan
Hampton Marvel tell those are your guys
they're gonna be looking to play
potentially not sitting just single high
rolls but over-the-top guys can I have
an ISO cam because I love it you know I
tried to become a Chiefs fan and let go
what let me and you guys made fun of it
and now I would like to officially
announce that I'm a Kansas City Chiefs
fan because the San Francisco 49ers have
just drafted a punter in the fourth
round of the NFL Draft and Matt I know
this this is a 49ers pick so I'm just
gonna sit back here why don't you just
go ahead and bring down a punter
position for us and what he will do for
your 49ers I want to say the real value
of this pick this guy ran a 4-6-3 at the
combine so the fake punt run is fully in
effect now the person is go Mitch wish
now ski yeah 6 to 218 athlete like
Connor said dual 20s actually is a
pretty good athlete
so Syria I remember watching him at the
combine it was like he ran better than a
lot of the quarterbacks but to take a
punter in the fourth round like I know
they've had their problems they're on
special teams like Robbie Gold's trying
to get traded right now I don't know who
the special teams coordinator is in San
Francisco you might want to work on your
bedside manner though because like
everybody's trying to run out of town he
did have a draftable grade according to
my notes we did not write scouting
reports on special teams players this
year's because we're not animals
so no scouting report will be sent out
but which now ski was here are my notes
good frame for a punter really good
athlete can adjust the pour snaps
played in bad weather at Utah and didn't
allow a lot of return yards so he did
not out kick his coverage which is some
people's goals did in that draft slide
we're not great now but way to go 49ers
like yeah give him something there with
John Lynch I think this guy really knows
what he's doing he's hit on Salomon
Thomas Rueben photographed a punter in
the four
it's round lookout NFC West because the
Niners are coming the Falcons have
traded up to I hate you so much the
bobbies have traded up to 111 overall
probably to get a kicker at this point
may there's a long snapper out there
there's a drafted idea I didn't know if
a punter would be drafted when we're on
you know last year Michael Dixon got
drafted and he actually was like an
all-pro Browns four and five today let's
say this draft pick hits and he is a Pro
Bowl punter is that worth a fourth round
pick it is it actually that's punter in
the lead I think it is with guys like
Deonte Thompson sitting there in
constant what would you trade or Justin
Tucker right now would you trade a
fourth round pick I'd trade first row I
think they decide games you only need a
punter if your offense is bad I'm trying
to make myself feel better about this
guys the Atlanta Falcons are on the
clock they trade it with Detroit the
pick is and will have it shortly and
hopefully it's something that will get
my mind off that the Washington Redskins
are on the clock then we have Baltimore
Seattle and Carolina don't forget you
can send in questions we'll answer them
here hashtag them be our draft you can
direct them to one of us to all of us
we'll take those questions it's we're
about ten picks in and everyone has
taken their five minutes this morning I
didn't expect that I thought we would
see more efficiency yeah we're not
getting that here and I remember hashtag
be our draft but complaints go to at NFL
draft scowl and always yeah I don't know
what John Lynch is doing I really don't
and I a lot of people have asked us
because of the comments made on the
podcast and stuff like why were you so
out on the 49ers and it's all John Lynch
for me I like Kyle Shanahan I like Jimmy
Garoppolo I I really do but I'm just so
done with John Lynch is the general
manager I think they got off to a great
start I mean Nick Bosa was is an
incredible player Devo Samuel is a
seamless fit in this offense but this is
something we discussed on sick the
football a lot is that the Niners get
really really cute in rounds three and
beyond so yes George kiddo was a
phenomenal pick but it's all the other
ones there's been a lot of misses here
and then you take a punter and maybe you
reduce your chances of missing but you
took a punter not only that a 27 year
old punter because he was at Utah so you
know he's yeah he's fine his prime
already for injuries you were the same
age as the 49ers fourth row I got a star
learn how to kick right get you out of
the gym stretching that leg out well I
mean he ran the same 40 as David
Montgomery and Josh Jake
right maybes gonna play right away you
are right though this is where the
Niners have struggled Joe Williams CJ
Beathard I mean even like Dante Pettis
last year there were moments but now
you're already drafting two receivers
this year it's easy to picnic Bosa it's
easy any of us could have done that any
of you would have done that it's harder
to build a team like think about the
Patriots the Ravens the Steelers they've
done really really well on day three the
Atlanta Falcons have made a pick guys I
think this one's gonna be a surprise to
you Kendall Sheffield okay hi Oh state
comes off the board someone that I was
told within the last month drop him on
your board kill him on your board
there were injury concerns he didn't
really work out through the pre-draft
process he is one of the fastest players
in college football but one of the
poorer cover men that we saw I think
over the past two years good god did he
struggle and it's disappointing I mean
you're talking about a former five-star
recruit with gigantic expectations and
legitimate legitimate dynamite speed but
when it comes down to it for Kendall
Sheffield I mean just hasn't he gets
beat up at the line of scrimmage and
that's not how it's supposed to go the
corner is supposed to get his hands on
the wide receiver there's times where he
falls off the line of scrimmage so
there's technique problems here I mean
you see it here you have some ball
skills he's an athlete so they're taking
him and saying hey maybe we can use his
speed as a gunner on punt teams maybe we
can develop him as a corner while we do
that but he's nowhere near ready to be
on the field right now yeah I think
they're just betting on that upside that
speed that you have to have in the NFL
he has it so if the Falcons can develop
him into anything
I like the value of it in the fourth
round it's I mean you're not drafting a
punter so congratulations and they they
had a need that drafted Isaiah Oliver in
the second round last year guys desmet
true Fox getting older remember they had
Robert Alford for a long time this is
kind of that type of player like a
speedy nickel but Sheffield needs
develop this is a guy who transferred
from Alabama it goes to Ohio State and
really needs a lot of work but the
measurable is that if he had ran the 40
yeah I think he would have been in the
fourth Reese I probably could have been
a 4-3 flat yeah he low for that million
wick we saw Parris Campbell blazing it
like a four 33 and I think Kendall
Sheffield is faster than that yeah four
three one for Paris Campbell and you
think Tyndall Sheffield's faster than
that so there's a lot of upside to this
pick can you teach a corner to cover
that's an interesting question you could
teach them to get better in coverage or
at least unique and that's been a huge
issue for him but he's just the
physicality is not there the frames not
there so once again though these are the
guys with traits and speed that we're
gonna see come off the board today but
you know we saw the door Jackson go in
the first round and I think Kendall chef
feels like that player and he went the
4th so maybe like Melo said maybe the
value actually is pretty good here
Washington Redskins on the clock they
have had one of the best draft yeah
which is not something we get to say
very often about what they do over there
in DC but my goodness what a draft look
at this beautiful read job on the
graphic guys
Dwayne Haskins lotta sweat and scary
Terry McClaren these I've seen these
three players all mocked in the first
round at one time for sure yeah I think
that's something that we talked about
last night kind of after the draft is
but you're right
Terry McLaren and scary Terry is a guy
that a lot of people had at the end of
the first round and the Redskins come
get him at 76 plus the pairing with his
quarterback that he had last year
there's already a relationship there you
have a rapport with that quarterback so
you're already a step ahead with Dewayne
Haskins who's your core your quarterback
of the future and probably right now
with the Redskins yeah and they had to
land at Collins and for agency Thank You
New York Giants so the Redskins are on
the clock it's interesting that Alaina
traded ahead of them guys maybe to get a
corner because I think that is the
biggest need for for Washington right
now we've seen the corner run happened
there are still some decent players out
there in the secondary though if you
wanted to add one we've seen an
obsession with Alabama players I don't
know that they would go Deonte Thompson
here but this front office loves Alabama
players think about John Allen Doron
Payne Landon Collins and it is not an
Alabama player it is a Stanford player
guys Bryce love comes off the board how
a player who two years ago was a Heisman
Trophy finalist 2000 yards rushing last
year hurts we're gonna grade this Pitt
guy so we'll save the analysis but Bryce
love goes 10th over on the fourth round
of the Redskins and it's it's an
interesting story with him because there
was talk after that breakout year of
like maybe this guy would be a
second-round yeah and then just gets
hurt and and they even tried to use him
or the way we asked them to you
three catches that first year at
Stanford this past year they did throw
him the ball more so it's a time of a
nice story to see a guy whose draft
stock maybe had really been hurt because
he had been hurt so much but 2017
Heisman Trophy finalist 2018
insignificant really as a football
player but the Redskins are betting on
they've never been afraid of a guy who's
been hurt so betting on a player who can
make a little bit of a comeback and
where is his timetable right now to be
back I mean that's a significant injury
that's my big question here yeah might
be a little bit of a redshirt season we
are gonna grade this pit guy so so get
those grades ready for Bryce love as a
value in the fourth round and I'm
writing I have this flipbooks amazing
all right all right so yeah so let's
just throw those grades up fellows Melo
what do you got on this bud I'm going C+
you alluded to it I don't know if this
guy can get on the field right now and
there are still a lot of good running
backs available we talked about the
running back out of Ohio State Texas A&M
guide treyvion Williams I think could go
justice Hill there's just a lot of
talent that's field ready they can come
on right now and contribute in that
backfield in special teams guys that we
know can catch the ball out of the
backfield to pair with Darius guys who
should be healthy but what if he's not
now you have two injured injured running
backs what are you gonna do we're giving
it a C+ I gotta change my grade yeah
it's a B for me and this is assuming
wrongfully probably but assuming that he
can come back to full form to the player
that he was as a junior he would have
went at the latest if he declared in the
third round that year he didn't he
stayed now he's hurt I'm with Melo my
problem here is there are some very
talented running backs on the board that
could have helped this Washington team
as they get Darius guys back on the
field this year would have been nice to
have somebody to really alter carries
and I'm gonna give it a see guys I
actually dropped that thanks to mellows
expert analysis and that's good point
when you have two running backs were
hurt who you getting of the ball to I
think that's a big question they do have
Adrian Peterson so they do have a
veteran that they can turn to hand the
ball to but hey I actually thought like
I would have dreamt at him in the sixth
round and taking a bet on oh if he can
get healthy a small running back who's
not been able to stay healthy is a
concern for me I would have drafted the
guy who just came off the board excuse
me number 11 overall justice Hill goes
to the Baltimore Ravens out of Oklahoma
State talk about production in college
this guy had it all can catch out of the
backfield I would not be shocked if
justice Hill is the starter for the
Baltimore Ravens by the end of this
football season okay yeah we really have
Mark Ingram that Mark Ingram just fine
but Mark Ingram has never really been
the guy you don't have to preach to me I
look at this he was my RB five and he's
still on the board here because about
what you're about to see you talk about
speed acceleration agility in the open
field a really high character
hard-working smart guy with great
athleticism just this hill this is
phenomenal value in this spot I
absolutely love this pick here so I
think for Baltimore that could have used
you know a different kind of change of
pace guy in their backfield after adding
Mark Ingram this is a really nice
selection yeah and I think really good
value I had him at 105 overall my board
and so coming off the board where he
does hear about the nine spots after
that is so it's a really good value I
could present a Duke Johnson I think he
is very small B he's a top-tier receiver
out of the backfield Melo we saw him a
lot in the big 12 would you think of
justice he'll he was a all big 12
freshman I mean this guy can really play
football he could fly on the football
field he can catch the ball on the
backfield we were talking about Brice
love I like justice so better so for the
Ravens to come pick him up you know
you're gonna run the football you have
Mark Ingram there this could be like I'm
not comping here but the Alvin Kamara
there that do everything back that can
come in and spell on third downs and and
help Mark Ingram carry the ball first
and second down yeah Mark Ingram doesn't
need that complimentary back the Vikings
are on the clock the Carolina Panthers
after that then the New York Jets the
Detroit Lions the New England Patriots
and actually the Vikings pick is in they
go back to the offensive line drew
Samiha offensive guard from Oklahoma so
a third Oklahoma offensive lineman comes
off the board
they were pretty good up front they got
another one Ben powers he's probably be
drafted today too so
the Oklahoma Sooners that offensive line
they actually won the Jo Moore award for
the best offensive line of college
football not a surprise yeah he's a
tough guy you see with the arm sleeve
there I remember a couple of times when
Kyler Murray got hit late he went to
fight whoever did that so I loved rusa
Mia's attitude and I liked it at this
point of the draft yeah I agree with you
too and we knew they needed offensive
line help now they get a guy who can
plug day
and I think come contribute on the
offensive line and help your quarterback
stay healthy
yeah they added Garrett Bradbury we'll
see where they move pad Alf line but now
you have a very physical he's right he
guard me yeah but you don't get a lot
from Oklahoma players they had nothing
ruined had a different attitude when you
look at Cody Ford obviously we talked
about Bobby Evans now Jerusem Mia you
see the honors there I mean that's no
joke this guy has played a lot and he's
played in a highly productive walk and
they had Orlando Brown last year that
was a special front five they had at
Oklahoma so which this Longhorn fan does
not like to say but the Vikings had a
need here Josh Klein is there right
guard and we've said for so long I wish
the Vikings would spend five picks on
the offensive line and just fix it well
they've spent - and I think this will
help them reshuffle what they want to do
up front you talked about like we want
to run the ball more we want to open
things up for Dalvin cook protect Kirk
Cousins or Kurt Kurt Kirk Kirk Kirk is a
joke remember it's Kirk inside joke yes
those aren't great on TV but this was a
big need for them I was trying to get
you guys to laugh and loosen up a little
bit so keep trying Matt you're almost
there but I do like the that worked
because if you want to keep your very
expensive quarterback healthy you want
to try to get Dalvin cook the ball and
see if he can really be productive you
better get him some old line help and
they do you mentioned it Oklahoma had
one of the best offensive lines in all
of college football last year so go
ahead and get one of those plug-and-play
guys to help your running back who's
very young and I don't think we've seen
the best of him yet lucky number 13 the
Carolina Panthers or come on the clock
guys and you were gonna love this pick
Christian Miller edge rusher from
Alabama and Connor says it you more when
he walked in that restaurant mobile and
we were like who's that
it looks good why is he playing here I'm
and it was cuz he was hurt a young is
built like a statue of an edge rusher 63
247 35 inch arm length like I know that
is that might not mean anything you guys
like I'm drooling it though live in
charm land you see it on film
he was my 57th overall ranked player and
they got him on day three the only
concern is that he's hurt a lot but you
watch it on a film from the outside he's
got ridiculous length as a pastor here
in long long arms he gets long arm move
swim rip I mean he really has it all as
a pass rusher a situational pass rusher
you see there now that's what you love
the ability to turn into the pocket and
crush the quarterback that's what person
Miller does play with that arm link
right there watching hands fight and
keep working be consistent you pair him
with Brian burns you should definitely
be able to get after the quarterback now
and you've addressed that need here with
with one draft you're right third down
potential here I don't care what he does
on first and second down he can get
after the quarterback eight sacks there
Alabama they had a very talented
linebacker group too so he wasn't always
on the field he was injured a lot eight
sacks with the time that he was on the
field is very impressive for a guy
coming out of Nick Saban I want to run a
three-four well Brian burns in Christian
Miller coming off the edge Luke Kuechly
and Shaq in the middle III would thirty
front third and long good luck against
Carolina that's what I'll say right
that's how Bruce Irvin so this is gonna
come from every speed explosiveness I
mean yeah very good Caroline really good
pick the New York Jets on the clock what
are you hoping for here buddy Foster
morrow I'm serious yeah they need a
second tight in they definitely do or
what about your guy Kelvin Harmon here I
mean that would be phenomenal
send it listen up text out to form Clark
big let's make Connor happy guys yeah I
don't have faith in them selecting
Kelvin harm and I don't think they
besides Jake I polite they don't agree
with me to off that's how we got George
get all of San Francisco so yeah you
look at the big board there obviously
Kelvin Harmon was the top guy available
there's a lot of talent left for this
offense Sam darling he got some help
yesterday with Schumer at Doga but he
needs some people to throw the ball to
ball still to whoa yeah but I mean they
have receivers there Robbie Anderson
Quincy and Noonan they signed Jameson
Crowder but you look at this offense
they still need young guys to develop as
backups because the Newton was ben-hur a
lot yeah with the value on the board
Marcus may has been banged up would you
consider Deonte Thompson as a third
safety yeah would because I think what
Gregg Williams he might be looking at
third safety and I think Jamal Adams he
plays in the front seven non-stop he
could do a lot of different things but
like you said Matt Marcus may has been I
really like the pic he had a phenomenal
rookie season he barely played last year
right corner is still a need for this
team they're hoping and praying that the
reader
Union of Gregg Williams and Tremaine
Johnson we'll get him back to bang
they're praying 15 million praying and I
got bad news for you the Jets traded out
they didn't take a punter it could be
worse they traded out the Tennessee
Titans are on the clock so Jack Pollard
wants to know before we know this pic
though guys who or each of us most
surprised is still on the board right
now I think it is Dion say Thompson yeah
I'm with you what do you think Noah I
would probably go with that too I mean
that's just an easy pick Riley Ridley is
a receiver that got a lot of attention
here you can see him number 67 on Matt's
big board I thought that he would go a
lot earlier I actually thought I was low
on Riley Ridley and that he was going to
come off the board in that second at
their ground but here he is still in
fourth so Tennessee Titans move up
we'll see who it is to attack we talked
about and they got big on defense
throughout this drafts they add Jeffrey
Simmons in the first round they get AJ
Brown Nate Davis this has been a really
good draft for the Tennessee Titans thus
far and I would actually advocate
strongly Nashville take Jairus to them
right now Marcus Mariota is done Ryan
Tannehill is a receiver take Jairus did
you know you had someone with some
talent that maybe could be a quarterback
wow you really are out on Mariota I
don't think you're crazy at all he's
just so average and I think your average
your bad at quarterback yes
you can't stay healthy fumbles in the
pocket too much I never really said oh
he doesn't throw interceptions in the
red zone guess what else he doesn't do
throw touchdowns in the red zone so I
mean look at last year he was just all
day average utter thereof Andy Dalton
the Marcus Moore I'm gonna steal Connors
theory here if you can't build up a team
blow it up don't stay there around 79
every year so if you get if you have
Marcus Mariota it's not working he
shouldn't be your quarterback next year
and Ryan Tannehill ain't the guy I'm
sorry it's not gonna work so if they did
go quarterback here I would really like
that pick for them it did not go
quarterback things like safety Imani
hooker
they signed Kenny Vaccaro or as a free
agent deal but they lose Johnathan
Cyprian so Monty hooker you just said
this not that long ago Connor kind of a
big nickel at Iowa he is and I know our
guy Matt Bowen loves Iowa safeties we
love Iowa Safety's very very smart
big big hitter can play down in the box
so a money hooker
we we liked this table out you can see
Christian Miller again
one more thing here so the Jets have
picked up two fifth round picks today
after coming in today with none they now
moved back from 116 to 121 and it looks
like they are going to 157 yeah it
actually traded 168 I actually like that
move because there's still good value on
the board so let's try to get back Melo
Imani hooker you liked it here for
Tennessee though I do he's he's a
variable guy it seems like pretty much
taking all that New England like
philosophy and he's bringing it with him
to Nashville 511 210 ran a 4 for 8 you
can find a spot for that on your defense
Patrick in honor man yes and they do
have two really good safeties Kenny
Vaccaro Kevin buyer buyer day is a free
agent
soon I believe but they gotta find a way
to lock him up look at this dude he can
be either one of those safeties so you
bring in a third safety that can play
over the top if you need to or he can
play in the box he can provide depth
while learning the position a little bit
more than you see him here at nickel
corner he fits in great with what they
need on that defense number 90 overall
on my big board so a really good pick
for them in terms of value all skills
like crazy here I mean and yeah there's
some production so I love his attitude
in the way he plays Iowa had some
players this year that just they live
and breathe football Hawkinson fan
Anthony Nelson now Monty hooker so this
is somebody that will play special teams
even need to sub package player he'll do
whatever you ask ray bowl loves those
it's also something about like the Iowa
uniforms are just the best so like
everyone looks better at Iowa when you
first when you got the paint when you're
gonna paint that face out like you get a
little bit of a notch up and toughness
for me interesting question you know I'm
from hash tag be our draft on Twitter I
want to throw your guys way our guy Jack
Pollard here is wondering if Washington
goes wide reciever again with their next
pick should they go after someone like
Calvin Harmon or Riley Ridley or do they
need a speedy guy like a manual halt
I would go speedy I was gonna say a
manual halt just get a guy that can come
and take the top off the defense you
already have scary Terry in there so go
ahead and go get a guy that can stretch
the field for you yeah I agree in you
want big Josh dachshund and Calvin
Harmon to me you're kind of the same guy
I don't know how many of those they just
like one-trick almost like sideline I'll
be reasonable though when it's game day
yeah that's the difference yeah so the
Detroit Lions are on the clock guys
here's the big board best receivers
available we'll take a look at that the
Lions could take a receiver that would
not be a surprise
Riley Ridley comes in from Georgia
possession
see where we talk about Calvin Hartmann
Emanuel Hall stretch receiver Preston
Williams is an interesting one
you watch Preston Williams game tape and
you think this dude is a first rounder
but he has some all filled he also
tested terribly at his pro day at
Colorado State so I think there's a lot
of questions right now if he's going to
be drafted but his potential was through
the roof I mean I'm with you all the way
I wonder the problem is for Preston
Williams is he gonna be on team boards
today that's what we want to know here
with him so yeah we're gonna wait I mean
you see him on the big board there right
there 1:17 I don't think that's where he
gets drafted though I think his value is
gonna be much much lower we're covering
rounds four and five for you here today
I don't know if we hear Preston Williams
name called while we're at the desk yeah
it could it would be a surprise but
we've seen you know team Cleveland Indy
candy City Cleveland does not care oh
they don't care down there up and to
pick so maybe maybe Cleveland Detroit
Detroit the pick is coming in then it's
New England on the clock
followed by Cleveland since Seattle I
can't read and then the New York Jets so
the Jets maybe if they take the pick
they might trade out again so while
we're waiting let's get to one more
question here this one from our buddy
Mason Whitlock hashtag PR drafted the
remaining quarterbacks was the best
chances of being a Pro Bowler I'm gonna
say Jackson just because the upside
Tyree Jackson can hit they we've already
talked about he's gonna have the second
strongest arm in Madden this is a guy
that could come in and develop over two
years and then take over for a team
maybe the Green Bay Packers or somebody
else he would be my pick to be a
potential Pro Bowler guys the Clemson
defensive line has now all been dradis
Austin Bryant defensive and goes to the
Detroit Lions clean and feral cam off at
for Christian Wilkins went Dexter
Lawrence went now the left defensive end
goes and actually they went order which
is kind of cool like from right to left
they came off the board in that order
you would go there yeah OCD softened
Bryan
there were times where he like you
watched him plays like man this dude I
said I made some plays it's really weird
the flashes are top 50 player flashes
when he disappears is when he starts to
fall back to doing a day three picks so
odd career for Austin Bryan
I mean his his spectrum is all over the
place but you see the burst and
acceleration with the closing speed
that's what you like in his game yeah
and he can set the edge I think he
be a strong side defensive end I
compared him to Kony Ealy I think it'd
be a good fit in Detroit they need many
more guys Trey flowers
Austin Bryant could work his way into
that lineup yeah I say number seven is
the one we're more used to seeing him
lying up in Melo did you like Austin
Bryant or were you all about others I
like some of the other guys that are
still on the board rather than Bryant he
is the one guy at Clemson that did not
see a double team you had to worry about
the other three depending on your scheme
you didn't know which one it was gonna
be it might be Wilkins might be furl
might be Lawrence and then oh yeah
Austin Bryant we can go ahead and cover
him one on one with our right tackle so
I do kind of worry about that but it's
Round four so if you like his up side go
ahead and take a flyer on him sometimes
well he didn't see anyone as we saw
we've got six blockers staying in we're
gonna take these three guys and then
we'll deal with Austin great work if you
could find it but yeah and I believe the
Patriots pick is coming in offensive
linemen it is going to be and I got to
read the pronunciation on this one guys
dildo hole yep yellow fro hole Arkansas
powerful offensive guard comes off the
board it's their style right sure does
he's he's an ass kicker yes what he's
gonna cover them do they told me not to
cuss I couldn't do it you guys remember
my guy Frank the tank last year from
Arkansas raised the discount version
that's what I want to be real with here
he will still put you in the dirt like
Frank the tank would so I'll get yelled
at fro ho
you know from IMG Academy originally
coming out of Florida so big
expectations there and he's gotten
better each year a lot of position
versatility he could play center or
guard
I think Pass Pro is gonna be an issue
for him at times but if you're looking
for a second level run blocker that
could punch you in the mouth he fits
exactly what no anyone likes and they do
have a need and we saw them add yah
Tanika just in the third round but
offensive guard Joe Thune E is sure
there's a really solid player he'll be
coming up soon Shaq Mason will be coming
up soon so you're looking at future need
I think for the the Patriots and depth
they they've needed depth any left go
mentioned that you know later in Waddell
is gone now Marcus cannon a really good
right tackle but they they need some
depth upfront and to see them actually
draft someone instead of just like
getting Kirk Ferentz his boy from Iowa
free-agent they're actually adding some
some valuable players here the Cleveland
Browns are on the clock guys that pick
will be coming in very shortly a team
that well they got Odell Beckham so
really doesn't matter who else they
drafted they drafted greedy Williams in
the second round and they get Sheldrick
red wine from Miami here and I actually
took I want to say I took a little flack
in my seven or mock draft that came out
on Thursday for putting him ahead of
guys like Jaquan Johnson and Michael
Jackson some of the Miami players who's
laughing now
yeah Sheldrick Redwine can play safety
he can play corner he's a very versatile
piece in the back end of the secondary
here I mean I'm not surprised at all I
know our buddy Jim naggy is stalking him
up a lot when you look at the safety
group here you start to get into the
it's Deonte Thompson slide by the way is
fascinating to me I don't know if it's
you know health related sighs related
but you look at an impact player here on
that Miami defense that had a lot of
them he was a reliable guy on the back
end next to Jaquan Johnson yeah and
again 6-foot tall at 202 pounds we ran a
four for four K so he can play all over
the defense for you actually that safety
was one of the like sneaky needs for the
Browns today so you get greedy Williams
opposite ends award Sheldrick Redwine
could play as that nickel safety you
have Morgan Burnett damarious Randall
they have some pieces in that secondary
I don't know that the Browns have any
needs anymore guys
now just take talent it's available for
them if they think it's read one I like
his fit because you need another corner
you have Ward you have greedy and now
you can put him in the nickel he can
spell it safety a little bit too so good
fit here I like the value to and those
are the safeties are left on the board
red wine we actually ranked at corner
for draft 400 Melo had him at 172
overall so a little bit early but again
if you are not sold with Yonsei thompson
here's the best remaining on the big
board the DBS we're starting to run out
of good d B's in this draft you already
have man yeah I mean Deion say Thompson
is sitting there I really do like Marvel
tell from USC as a cover guy with a lot
of upside in his game but I mean it's
the run has come and gone my ten top ten
corners have been gone that's for sure
now the safeties are coming off the
board like crazy here one more hashtag
be our draft to throw your guys way what
remaining tight end would fit well in
the Cowboys offense those that Melo and
does they pass tomorrow so I'll take
this one out yeah you guys take it from
here yeah no I mean Ron Wescoe would be
one West
would be actually who I was gonna
highlight because he is kind of the
h-back roll out of West Virginia who we
saw it the Senior Bowl and talked to his
head coach he thinks he can do
everything and what we saw at the senior
role I would agree with that he is much
more than just a move tied in you could
put him on the end of the line you could
put him out in the slot he he's a very
good product yeah I will go with a late
one here but I think Andrew Beck from
Texas is a similar guy who a lot of the
like name tight ends you would recognize
Katie Smith
Alizee Mack they tested terribly Andrew
Beck was the opposite he was someone
Isaac Nauta tested very poorly but
Andrew Beck played fullback aged back
tight in at Texas and then tested really
well at the pro day which I wouldn't be
surprised if he did jump some of those
bigger name like in line tight ends that
a lot of people would recognize and that
sounds like a Homer pick but you're
right because he's a locker room guy too
came in was a captain at Texas willing
blocker can do it things underneath he's
probably not gonna stretch the seam for
you it tied in but we're in the fourth
round we're in day three of the draft if
you could get a guy like that you're not
gonna have a problem something he's
gonna come in he's gonna work his butt
off and he's gonna produce for you so
Seattle the pick is in waiting on that
pick here they've had an interesting
draft here so far a couple of reaches
but guys that fit with that Seattle
scheme let's see if they go for a little
more upside a couple reaches for sure
you know getting wide receiver DK
Metcalf fell right into your laptop and
talked that now maybe maybe we've seen
the end of Doug Baldwin but Cody bargain
was a reach I thought Marquis Blair
being the second or third say a few up
the board was a very big surprise but
they're drafting like inside kind of
guys that bit their scheme which is
super important there no offensive line
picks yet for Seattle which has to be
listed as one of the biggest needs that
they could ever have your pick 120 every
year the problem is offensive line not
very many good ones left here guys I
mean it is you haven't you have any
tackles left in your top ten I I know
mine is falling apart Dennis Daly the
only tackle left in my top ten and then
I have two interior guys Phil Hanes and
Michael Jordan who I was looking at his
depth guys I was not looking at them as
getting on the field right away here
Michael Jordan I know he played center
he said he feels most comfortable at
guards that's an interesting one right
there yeah so they actually go wide
receiver they go another layup physical
guy Robo
Guerry voice receiver from West Virginia
mellow unification we talked to Dana
Holgorsen we asked about Gary Jennings
and he was like Algarrobo Gary say he's
just a he's an athlete and that's what
Gary Jennings says so the Seahawks have
now added two of the most physically
impressive receivers in this class this
is different than what we've seen them
doing the past with like Tyler Lockett
Paul Richardson like small speedy guys
they're getting some size for Russell
Wilson yeah this is discount DK right
here he's not a big he's not as fast but
if you put both of you let's see how far
Russell Wilson get to really throw the
football because both of these guys can
stretch the field and go get it and one
thing I love about Robo Gary's game is
he catches and tracks everything the
ball just sticks to his hands so I know
you guys done that very well being Texas
fans but sorry no wow he came through
here to be our Gary is awesome
Preparation off the charts and I think
he's gotten buried in this wide receiver
group because maybe not flashy maybe as
we talked about more of a straight line
speed kind of guy but I actually liked
his floor a lot better than most of the
receivers left here on day three
surprising for me is that he went ahead
of David sills who was a more complete
receiver David sills dominated in the
red zone you'll remember he's the guy
who was like 14 and Lane Kiffin gave him
a scholarship to USC as a quarterback
he tried to play quarterback for a long
time it didn't work out they put him at
receiver at West Virginia yeah and back
to back West Virginia boys the New York
Jets Connor have taken trevone Westco
great pick I know you're excited you've
been saying they need another tie dealer
he could play fullback he could play
tight in I want to go back to that
Senior Bowl week sitting in the BR box
up in the luxury suite that we had
stocked and you're watching you got like
your binoculars trying to watch these
players and trevone Wesco because they
just have their team helmet on you're
like who is this and then it's like oh
my god that's trevone Wesco he caught
everything that week yeah he really did
and I mean we love the versatility we
talked to Dana Holgorsen about him he
was a big fan obviously of the player I
think he's a better athlete than given
credit for it but this guy is gonna be
asked to block a lot for Adam GaSe and I
think he can do it too you can plug him
in as an old traditional tied in and
help free up your very expensive running
back that you have now and also being
underneath target for Sam d'Arnaud than
what he can do on that offense yeah he
is a big dude six three and a half 270
pounds so this is
not an up the seam move tight end this
is an old-school like Melo said you
might put him at H back he might be
kicking out defensive ends he's gonna
help set the edge in the run game
offensively to get those linebackers
defensive inside of the play Le'Veon
Bell bounced a little bit yeah this
makes sense the Jets want to run the
football and they want to get creative
in the way they do so so you get a guy
that can get outside and open up those
outside zone runs for levy on this it's
not a surprisingly this pick is an Adam
GaSe pick all the way I mean he this is
the time that he should be in the war
room getting his guys that valuable and
really scheme fits this is one the 99th
overall player on my board ty ten nine
so now you're seeing the tight ends come
off the board here the only two left in
my top ten would be foster Marone Kaden
Smith at Foster Morrow a little bit of a
surprise but he was banged up as a
senior that could be why he's falling
guys the Pittsburgh Steelers around the
clock followed by the Baltimore Ravens
Seattle Seahawks actually come back on
the clock and then the Cincinnati
Bengals so the Steelers traded up to get
Devin Busch we absolutely loved that
pick for them they've had I think a very
solid draft just addressing physical
guys Deante Johnson ref replacing
hopefully Antonio Brown the mellow
Justin Lane we didn't get to see you
when this pick came in I know you love
this dude no I didn't love the picked up
because it comes right in front of my
team but I do love Justin Lane I know
he's a little bit physical he's a little
bit handsy but I kind of like that
especially at the line of scrimmage
especially for the Pittsburgh Steelers
if he can get his hands on some of these
guys like Odell Beckham in and Javon
Landry or you know a dream I like him
especially where they got he was one of
my favorite corners in the draft I
thought he would go second round so for
the Steelers to get him I think he
immediately comes into that defense and
he can make plays and produce for you
get already burns off the field the
Steelers we could see them go a lot of
positions here they did trade up to get
a linebacker they could go edge rusher
TJ waters been very good bud Dupree kind
I'm in a mixed bag we don't seem good
quarterback they did this last year they
took Josh Dobbs in the middle of the
draft but it wouldn't be a surprise I
don't think to see them you guys
mentioned Tyree Jackson yeah this would
be a really good fit for him he's an
athlete that is a downfield passing game
Roethlisberger signed an extension but
he is getting a little bit older now I
think it's a great landing spot for
entire Jackson I'm curious to see we're
gonna see how much they like Josh Dobbs
because you know he's obviously a
brilliant brilliant
like a kid and just the way he prepares
I think on the field that's been up and
down for him so far so curious to see if
they do decide to add a quarterback and
they actually went running back guys so
giving Benny excuse me drafting Benny
Snell giving jay lerner background yeah
that's the Steeler I'm so glad you said
that Benny Snell incredibly physical
super productive this last year at
Kentucky before six six speed
I think bumped him down the board but
again incredibly productive almost 1,500
yards rushing we're gonna grade this
pick guys haven't done that in a minute
so get ready do it
Le'Veon Bell goes out Benny Snell comes
in for the Pittsburgh Steelers sometimes
teams pick a player and you're like yep
like you said that's the Steelers a
David Montgomery that's a bear
yeah it's Fitz the Pittsburgh Steelers
sit around for a day mean mother at
running back Benny Snell is physical and
he knows it one of the most confident
guys in the 2019 Trapp class Connor Jay
Rogers what are your thoughts on finding
Snell Junior I mean I like the pickier
he fits perfectly he's a straight line
runner a power runner he's gonna put his
shoulder down and knock you backwards
and that's what you get here I think
he's actually a better pass catcher than
giving credit for but he's not a change
of direction guy you see right there
very straight line tough runner I mean
he fits in the offense he's not gonna be
asked to come in and start that's why
James Connors there but he's a guy that
can really be that not change of pace
but more or less somebody to take the
load off of him at times and split the
carry so this pick for me is a B there's
a couple running backs on the board I
still like your better whether it was
Rodney Anderson Kuran Higdon but this
bit is perfect for him yeah and we did
see him fall and I think a lot of it is
that four four six I'm gonna be plus
though I really like this pick the
Steelers they always find running backs
later in the draft and I think this is
just another example of that a guy
that's gonna come in and really help
James Conner just like we saw James
trying to do with levy on bail so good
job by the Steelers here to go and get
another running back for that stable in
the back to 4-6 6-4 4-6 they've been
great yeah 46 because I'm actually gonna
give it an a-minus like you said I love
the fit I think it was a little bit of a
reach with some of the running backs on
the board but there's a team that knows
their needs they understand their scheme
bidding Snell is a powerful back let's
see him and some goal line is short
yardage situations helping out the
Pittsburgh Steelers
all right the Baltimore
even's round-the-clock that picks in and
then again the Seattle Seahawks don't
forget questions we want to answer them
Connor is going through Twitter right
now just hashtag them be our draft
otherwise we're too busy we're not gonna
find them so not use the hashtag yeah
here's an interesting one from Jordan
here
what's going on with Mack Wilson and
Deonte Thompson do you think Saban was
bitter about them leaving and trashed
them two teams so I don't think so and I
that's a good point because we've always
heard rumors about that happening and I
talked to some college coaches
throughout this process about that very
thing and one told me he said I would
never do that because next year I'm
gonna have a guy that I believe in and I
want to be able to tell those NFL scouts
hey you should take a look at this guy
so coaches especially Nick Saban he's
been in the NFL he knows how this works
and Alabama has the most open process of
any college if you're a scout you go
down there they will feed you they will
hand you the clicker you can watch film
you could talk to whoever you want so
could this happen with maybe a jaded
coach on the way out yes but I can't see
Nick Saban doing that yeah I don't think
so either I don't think yes sir they
were thrashing those guys I think also a
problem here with Mack Wilson and I fell
victim of this early on until I finished
the tape was those guys up front let you
run around and make plays
he was just okay this year he was not on
the level of Sean Evans CJ Mosley he was
not that kind of Alabama linebacker what
did you think Melo I agree with you two
I think that guys like Quinn and
Williams in the beginning of the year we
thought man this Mack Wilson guys all
over the field
wait it's number 92 that's really
helping him stay clean and get through
there so I agree with the Mack Wilson
trade I know that I had graded him and
mocked him in the first round early in
their process but then you start to see
him slide in it's like well maybe he's
the second round guy maybe he's a third
round guy so now we're starting to see
him fall even maybe into the fourth
round if not later guys the Baltimore
Ravens made their pick last year around
this time they took an Oklahoma player
it turned out pretty good Orlando Brown
jr. they're gonna back to the well when
norm and they get Ben powers Oh
so four or Homa offensive linemen have
now been drafted maybe that's good news
for us Texas Longhorns maybe they won't
be eating good next year or maybe
they'll just keep recruiting the best
offensive lineman in the country yeah
left guard here I think more of an
athlete we saw drew Samia come off the
board he's more of a physical player so
and athlete Ben powers who I believe is
a left Bob Marshall Yonder is getting
older he does play on the right side but
this is a future need for the Baltimore
Ravens and we can keep this rolling guys
the Seattle Seahawks saw a guard come
off the board they drafted a guard Phil
Haynes this do displayed all over the
offensive line at Wake Forest he is
physical so Phil Haynes goes to the
Seattle Seahawks they do address the
offensive line finally yeah this is what
you'd like to call one of those phone
booth kind of blockers if he gets you in
that type tight space and gets his hands
on you it's over for you Phil Haynes and
stuff and I think one of the most
important games to watch in his career
is against the Clemson front four which
was all drafted he handled Dexter
Lawrence's power a lot better than most
guys would so I like Phil Haynes and
it's good to finally see them address
the offensive line yeah and I think they
must be watching the stream with
everybody else too because we said
there's not very many offensive linemen
available so you better get the ones
that are there and that are good I like
Ben powers it's hard to say that as a
Texas fan but he's very good at football
and these Oklahoma guys are all going to
contribute the first day that they get
into camp I really like the game and
what they're gonna be able to do for
every team that's selected it was pretty
Pro ready coming out of Oklahoma right
now and yeah hey guys they can move all
over the field they're strong like Bobby
Evans one of the most powerful upper
bodies I looked at this whole year the
Cincinnati Bengals around the clock that
picks in then we have Chicago Baltimore
and the Dallas Cowboys another BR draft
question here thank you so much guys for
sending those in this one from goose are
there any centers left for the Jets ooh
good question Gil yeah there were like
three in this whole draft yeah that's
the problem and they all came out Farley
I think Gilyard from Georgia is the
top-rated center left on the board you
started looking at guys like you said
Michael Jordan who played Center at Ohio
State he's most comfortable at guard
like you said Connor so it is really
getting down to the bottom of the barrel
if you need someone you might be looking
at a guy that might have to move like a
small tackle who could come in and play
a center or a guard that could come in
at play but it's it's not a great group
at that position they showed the Jets of
war room and there's seven empty chairs
and Mike McKagan everybody else is gone
we're out on lunch there's yeah that's
it yeah I said it was a gates pick
earlier there's only one guy in the room
right now so hopefully he's texting Mike
mckagan but yeah Center is a tough one
and I forgot Ross Pierce Walker from
from Alabama I actually had around four
or five grand on him so not not a great
athlete not a super twitchy player but
really really tough physical guy at the
point of attack so he would be one that
you could see here maybe could could
come in and be a bit of a maybe a
starter down the road possibly I mean
all right we got the pic here guys
Cincinnati Bengals go d-line Rennell ran
from Arizona State some of them got
recommended to us by our buddy naggy who
runs the Senior Bowl six-foot-five
almost 300 pounds he can play leaked
really good athlete he could play
anywhere along the defensive line so I
need for them Geno Atkins is getting
older they haven't drafted particularly
well at the defensive line position the
past several years so they might have
got this one right because he is an
athlete yeah of course Carl Lawson
unfortunately got her and it looked like
he was off to a fantastic start to his
career so you bring in a guy like Wren
that maybe the production in college and
why you all the time but in terms of raw
athleticism he's got it yeah and he can
play nose tackle too if you need him to
if you want to keep Geno around for a
little bit he can come in and provide
depth right here in the fourth round for
a defensive line that really needed a
lot of help
he had a great build I compared him to
Hakeem Hicks I had a third round great
or an L Rin so really good value a
really good question here from Andrew
hashtag PR draft
where would Rodney Andersson ranked in
this year's running back class if there
was no injury concern well the problem
is there were three years of injury so
it's almost impossible to say because
we've never evaluated him in college
without an injury and it would these are
big injuries like it was an ACL it was a
foot injury these are a big concern so
there were times when healthy he looked
like a first rounder though yeah I mean
I had compared him to Arian Foster I
think he's a big running back they can
catch the ball out of the backfield but
you can't ignore those injury problems
because he wasn't able to get on the
field at Oklahoma because of the
injuries if let's say perfect world that
never happens I still wouldn't have him
ahead of Josh Jacobs David Montgomery
Mile Sanders so then we started to talk
about running back for running back five
for me if he were healthy yeah guys we
do have a pick we're gonna grade the
Chicago Bears draft Riley Ridley wide
receiver out of Georgia so one of the
top players available on our big board
comes off the board guys the Chicago
Bears did Mitchell try Biscay some help
with a route runner from Georgia might
recognize the name his brother Calvin
doing some things in
Riley Ridley is the pick at 126 Connor
one of the better route runners I sold
this year what did you think of Ridley
I'm with you we saw this guy against LSU
when he got into a dogfight with greedy
Williams so we absolutely loved this
player and I think at this point at the
trap he's perfect for this offense he's
somebody that we often say this with
Matt and Aggie you know scheme him open
you don't have to it this guy he'll find
a way to get open on his own sure in the
other the combine doesn't really wow you
that's not his game he catches
everything he finds a way to get open
for me this is an a all the way at this
point of the draft mellow yeah I'm right
there with you again Conor Rogers I'm
going a plus you look at what they did
last year at receiver they found a guy
later in the draft I think they just did
the same thing again with Riley Ridley
exceptional route runner he's gonna help
Mitch try Biscay maybe be the pro-bowl
quarterback that they want him to be
yeah guys I'm gonna agree with you I'm
gonna give it an a let's just say he's
across the board Riley Ridley one of my
favorite route runners and as we believe
on stick to football sometimes the
younger brother is almost as good as the
big brother so I think he's gonna be
able to make make some things happen
very good hands receiver the Bears get a
wide receiver and wrap for that we
bleeps gonna make a big impact
all right keeping this thing going the
Eagles have the last pick of this round
and our buddy Jake you wants to know
will there be a safety edge or
linebacker left for them by that Mack
Wilson and Deon say Tom Alabama just see
what they have available they probably
got a guy for you especially at safety
in line but it's crazy I believe David
long is still on the board am I wrong
there he is right there he that's the
only problem David long he's a player
you said the guys who sometimes are like
guys a bulldog David long junior it's
just a bulldog for West Virginia I he
was not that different on tape and Devon
Bush no and I talked to teams that were
obsessed with his character so I'm kind
of wondering here you think at this
point you take the risk of he's one of
my favorite players left fit for the
Eagles for me I would go vote John
Joseph I think he can come in and be
your Jordan Hicks a guy that can be in
coverage and play against the run he was
so good in coverage I thought he was a
safety for the first two games that I
scouted him on he can really sink his
hips back and get into coverage much
like they had with Jordan Hicks so I
think if you need value at linebacker
you could go get him he's a three down
linebacker interestingly enough I
compared Fauchon Joseph to jordan Hicks
in my school report so good job I stole
that from me probably should Frank did
the Ravens are on the clock go up though
guys we've seen them go wide reciever a
couple times in this draft Myles Boykin
Hollywood Brown they had at justice Hill
they've really tried to build up this
offense for Lamar Jackson last year they
did a great job getting Orlando Brown
they added a lot of tight ends last year
maybe we see defense come off the board
here I mean the added Earl Thomas
they're pretty good at safety with
Keenan Tony Jefferson I like Marlon
Humphrey a lot of corner they added
Jalen Ferguson as a pass rusher so
inside linebacker could be a need here
yeah I would say so too in you know if
Ozzie Newsome was still there Mac Wilson
would be gone no chance he's available
here but maybe a guy like tre Lamar out
of Clemson is another guy I do think
that they need to go middle linebacker
here you lost a very good player to the
New York Jets so you have to fill that
need I would do it right here in the
draft that Alabama pipeline issues did
you guys know Ozzie Newsome never
drafted an LSU player inflated Alabama
that's right in the Hall of Fame there
and he never as GM or the Ravens drafted
a player at LSU only missed on some good
ones over the years that would that
would be me if I were a GM it would be
like okay here's Baker Mayfield here's
Tyler Murray no thanks I'm good I'll
taste and Arnold fine inspecting those
Alabama guys our buddy Richard royal
wants to know lots of talk about Mack
Wilson and Deonte Thompson being
available what about Isaiah bugs I did
not like his tape and the coaches
destroys that right him so the Ravens
actually win defense guys but they went
corner biggie Marshall out of USC same
on Marshall five-star recruit I believe
coming out of high she was fantastic
athlete everyone talked about oh my gosh
this is gonna be the next dude never
really happened you like it six career
picks at USC but he looks the part six
foot one 207 pounds he is an athlete and
they need depth at the corner position
and I thought he would be a better
safety at the next level of it just
because his biggest problem is turning
and running down the field now when you
look at the type of player they like
Marlin Humphrey obviously being the
premium version but this actually makes
sense they believe they can give this
guy the help over the top you see the
problem right there with that excellent
play you didn't turn around and find the
football he found it you know what his
back turned to the ball but this is what
he can do he will come and make the
tackle
he's a very physical football player I
just think once again his cover skills
and man
or what do you think no I agree with you
100% and I think that's something that's
a conversation we had at Senior Bowl
this guy should be playing safety he
loves to come up and hit 48 tackles
there from the corner spot that's tough
to do we said guys you already drafted
have like 20 and you're like okay this
guy will come up and play the run but
not like I'm on Marshall I love his
value he can come in be your day 1
starter in the nickel probably provides
some depth at safety and maybe even
develop into an outside corner yet pick
what 127 this that's pretty good value I
adament 154 overall but we've seen the
run on DBS happen pushing guys like this
up the board so the Dallas Cowboys are
on the clock again a team that they
actually put out on Twitter in the first
round that they had drafted Amari Cooper
which I like the troll job there they
did a good job with that we could see
them go I think a lot of different
positions and we talked about they were
interested in another running back and
actually I was just told they did go
with a running list everybody did this
Toni Pollard who not just a running back
though a Swiss Army knife on offense I
mean he really is you want to talk about
explosive players from that Memphis
offense this is another one of those
guys yeah a guy that can really catch
the ball out of the backfield - I know
they have Darrell Henderson from Memphis
but Tony Pollard can do it too and it
fourth round he gives depth to Zeke and
he can contribute on special I thought
he was faster than his four or five -
it's like he didn't time as well but I
see him as a good complement to Zeke
because Zeke is all about the power in
the inside game and bouncing runs I
would get Tony Pollard involved on jet
sweeps I would throw him so many swing
passes get him working in the screen
game and almost no wear and tear because
he did share all those reps with draw
Henderson when they were at Memphis so I
like Tony Pollard's usage he was like
the poor man's like Torrey Cohen in this
draft just didn't have that tested speed
like we expected I will say I thought
some other running backs would be
drafted much higher than he was I would
have probably pegged him for a sixth
round running back here just but based
off what's still available but he can't
come in and do everything and it might
be for his return ability that might be
a big part of this selection it is an
interesting draft for Dell so far even
if you add in Amari Cooper Tristan Hill
player that the coaching staff really
didn't like it UCF this last year but a
high up side scouts did Connor McGovern
we'll see if Lyle Collins I don't know
if they can afford to keep him long term
so Connor McGovern
might play guard if Connor Williams goes
to tackle there's a lot of chess pieces
that are involved right now at the
cowboys offensive line and now you get
kind of an upside running back special
teams player and Tony Pollard the
Oakland Raiders are on the clock that
pick is in it'll probably be from a
power five school knowing Mike may I
could probably team captain yeah high
character guy or maybe they just keep it
going with the developmental guys like
they did with Crosby here the Raiders
are having a very good draft and I know
that I have a lot of picks so it's easy
but I really like what they're doing we
questioned Mayock coming from that media
role into a real GM spot
I think he's crushing it so far him and
Gruden they've taken a lot of flack you
traded a lot of guys before they got in
there you send your Scouts home dude
what a bang-up job in my opinion and the
pick is a corner Isaiah Johnson from
Houston a big corner so they go Trayvon
Mullen now they come back with Isaiah
Johnson this secondary is a lot better
six foot two and change 208 pounds we
saw him at the Senior Bowl guys he's got
the size he's got the length up side
player we're gonna grade this pick oh
boy so get that one ready Isaiah Johnson
from Houston a player that yeah we all
really like once we got to see him a
person I think the Oakland Raiders get a
big corner to go opposite Trayvon
Maloney carry on kindly guys Isaiah
Johnson from Houston a dynamic player at
6-foot to almost 210 pounds this is a
player you know what Seattle the
Chargers the Niners the Jags he fits
that mold of a big physical outside
corner yeah we've seen a lot of corners
with great length and speed get drafted
early here whether it was greedy
Williams obviously Tampa went with Shaun
bunting in Jamel Dean this is the next
guy up here in Isaiah Johnson you talk
about 4/4 speed can jump out of the gym
he's got ball skills he clearly can
tackle so I like this pick alive this
point of the draft if you need a long
corner that can run down the field this
is it this is an a-minus for me I love
the value in this situation yeah and I
think we're gonna see the Raiders be
that next team that loves the tall
physical corners because that's what
Isaiah Johnson is and you can compare
him to even his own teammates Trayvon
Mullen now with the draft and Gary on
Conley they have a type they're in
Oakland now and they go fill that there
I think their type might just be good
players guys mike Mayock in your first
draft your
an amazing job and a pic for me I'd I
say it Johnson graded is a third or
fourth round fringed player they get him
here at the end of the round mike Mayock
is making us guys who sit at a desk look
a lot smarter than only actually are
he's doing a very good job the Raider is
having one of our favorite drafts i
isaiah johnson comes off the board in
round four yet max doing a good job and
i think we can take a second actually
talk about that because there were a lot
of skeptical people and we even said
like first round is gonna be pretty easy
let's see what Mayock does when he gets
into the nitty-gritty of the second
round there it is round team building
and they have attacked positions of need
and it done a really good job that we
saw them free to see they got receivers
they got a left tackle and now they're
going after we needed an edge we're
getting an edge they are the best
running back in the trap they got the
best safety in the draft and now we see
two corners once you add in Isaiah
Johnson Trayvon Mullen I'm gonna gush
about he was one of my favorite dudes
that we watched this year I mean I think
just they've taken a lot of high floor
players but now they're actually taking
some up side players here later in the
draft which I'm a big fan of doing that
I feel like you look for traits to
develop those traits and Isaiah Johnson
Trayvon Mullen max Crosby those are
those types of guys they test really
well I think mike Mayock is having a
really really strong first draft yeah
and I agree completely again in in the
fourth round you can take a chance on an
Isaiah Johnson at Houston and a Max
Crosby and see if they can be a boom
pick that diamond in the rough kind of
4th round draft choice if not it's a
fourth round draft choice you bet on the
traits you bet on being able to develop
these guys the rest of the way coming
from the smaller schools like the
Houston you can develop him into a very
good corner guys the other people stream
showing the draft throw commercial we
are not no commercial breaks no pee
breaks we're just talking ball here
we'll see about the boards of biz ran
I'm just lightening well hydrated people
like I use hydration is overrated we got
some questions though hashtag be our
draft on Twitter Luke
Joshua Nemeth that's an at nimeth Luke
yeah three names that's scary man should
the Lions pick a quarterback in the
later rounds I mean one for me once
Tyree Jackson and Siddim are off the
board here maybe Brett ripping play
Gardner Minshew
you can have
yeah I don't I don't know that I would
draft quarterback late in the rounds
here I think I would try to fill that
need you need a backup quarterback I
don't think you're trying to replace
Matt Stafford in the fourth or fifth
round not with the guys that are
available so if I'm the Lions I'm
probably gonna pass all I'm taking a
quarterback Clayton Thorson might be an
option but again I would just fill that
backup role with maybe some young free
agents Matt Stafford can stay healthy
enough for you next year I think is when
we start to see maybe the lines and
address that and you just jinxed it
staffers gonna hurt training camp now
good job now look how both hers Thomas
Rowe Hagin cancer are you concern the
Chiefs excuse me he's concerned the
Chiefs have not addressed a corner
position what do we see the value in the
sixth round or could a wand or hill from
Virginia be moved to corner so I'm not
as worried because bashad Breeland came
in afraid yeah I know like these are not
great names at corner you hope Kendall
fuller plays better this year I do not
think one Thornhill has a corner I think
he's a safety all day but their belief
has to be that those two great safeties
and their pass rush can help them what
in the sixth round it's gonna be hard to
get a player in some come in and make up
an impact you see the corners left on
the board I actually really really like
Jordan Brown from South Dakota State if
he's somehow available guys but the San
the Los Angeles Chargers have made their
pick maybe a bit of a surprise
drue tranquill from Notre Dame a
linebacker who started there as a safety
high character workout dude weight room
dude locker room good football post a
good player he's gonna help on special
teams
they were very weak in the middle of the
field there was talk maybe even they
might have even got a linebacker in the
first round at one time or another but
they get drue tranquill dude rock that
see a Notre Dame like this is a leader
through three yeah you want to talk
about someone that can be a ten-year
captain in your special teams this is
the guy now what's crazy is he came back
from injury played at a high level and
tested off the charts and I think that's
what got him here in the fourth round so
I love this pick for Los Angeles I
actually wouldn't even be surprised to
see him on the field in sub package
situation oh yeah they I mean obviously
the Chargers love their Notre Dame
linebackers and this guy can come in
he's going to contribute on special
teams he can cover because he played
safety at Notre Dame as well and he's a
real
wife and he does have a rule so you
don't have to worry about hat
distraction
no fake girlfriends for him the Chargers
draft so far they like Notre Dame Jerry
Tillery in the first round this year at
early from Delaware in the second tray
Pipkins from Sioux Falls gonna third and
the drue tranquill in the fourth so
they've booked ended here with Notre
Dame players not my favorite draft I
like Tillery with this for three under
defense that they're gonna run this year
at early I think Gus Bradley saw maybe
this might be like a junior Earl Thomas
leap over the top but yeah Pipkins the
graduate program from South Bend is now
in Los Angeles so night not that bad I
drew tranquil as my 10th ranked
linebackers so this is perfect value for
me I like it a lot yeah the Redskins are
on the clock that pick will be coming in
we have time for another question
between the pylons wants to know are
there any more day one starters left on
our boards let's take a look here I mean
I still think David Long juniors a
phenomenal player who probably has to
play a Marc Baron kind of role so if you
have that role in your defense he could
be today one starter you look at Matt's
for here Matt what do you think from
these guys 10 guys still left on my top
100 I think that Yonsei Thompson well I
don't know what's going on with the
injury there I think both shot Joseph
could be a starter David long junior
definitely could John Jay Walker was
hurt Joe Jackson not a fit for everyone
but we have the pick for the Redskins
West Martin offensive guard from Indiana
played left guard for the Hoosiers in
2018 need for them they are getting a
little bit older up front
obviously Brandon Scherff is a really
good player at right guard this could be
a left guard back up you know third
guard maybe something I hope can work
into the lineup eventually yeah this is
someone I thought would be a sixth or
seventh round kind of player here so I
think the value is off but we saw the
run on offensive lineman go quite quick
so I'm not too surprised if there is
reach in that area I mean Michael Jordan
still sitting on the board so little
surprise there what do you guys think
yeah I would thought we would see
Michael Jordan come off the board a lot
quicker than we did but I'm there must
be some concerns there with him if he
can play guard is he a tackle but if you
need offensive lineman you're probably
gonna have to come up and get one I
don't have too many left I think that if
you were to drive offensive lineman for
the rest of the day you should probably
do it in the fourth round because come
round five round six
I don't know that we're really gonna
have very many draftable oh so Wes
Martin go so that tells you that the
wrought offensive lineman is come and
gone a shorter guy he's under six foot
three 311 pounds so I think it's more of
a power gap mover type player a little
bit of a surprise like you said guys
with the Ohio State players on the board
there's Alabama center Wisconsin Center
both those guys people think could play
guard as well so maybe a little bit of a
reach here they might we talked about
Daniel Snyder and he had to try to mess
one up here on us so we had a question
for Brazil guys Paulo Costa a question
straight from Brazil should the Vikings
keep going oh line in the later rounds
or should they go best player available
and find the best value I mean you're
starting to run out of guys that's the
problem we found here I mean yeah
Michael Jordan might be one of those
names left Dennis Daly a tackle in case
they're not sold on their tackle
situation all the way right now but
they're out on offensive line has come
and gone unless you want a stash guy
that you could develop good luck at this
and they have not gone defense yet in
this draft there's nothing's interesting
there's been talked to Trey Wayne's
could be on the move there's talked at
Xavier Rhodes could be on the move and
the trade block they did draft herb
Smith so Kyle Rudolph there's been also
talked to he's maybe done there so I
would like to see them go defense I
wouldn't reach right now for offensive
linemen I would try to stack on defense
or latch they got holding hills I
believe an undrafted free agent if not a
very late round pick and he looked like
a good player as a rookie so I would
keep going best player available and we
have another hashtag be our draft
question here from our buddy Patrick
Chamberlain he wants to know any chance
the Giants try to trade generous Jenkins
now that they've added three young good
cornerback since Sam build the Andre
Baker and Julian love I think the thing
there is that you know would you nourish
Incans is and you do not know what those
guys can do like you had high hopes
because they were all drafted early but
that's a loaded corner room right now
and I think generic Jenkins has not been
incredibly happy since coming to the New
York Giants so you probably are
investigating it salary becomes a bit of
an issue there as well guys the Seahawks
have made a pick and they went with a
versatile defensive back from Oregon you
go Ahmadi who I listed as a safety
I believe he's being listed by them as a
corner someone who probably a nickel
player he's not their type at all he's
under 510 199 pounds but he played that
nickel spot for Oregon tough dude
and you talk about teams that try to
fill need we saw them go
you know safety early we thought maybe
this is like marquis blair they're
hoping to get their old thomas this
might be that nickel corner that they're
trying to get here yeah they have
reached a couple of times but this is
one of those undersized players that can
handle a couple different roles in
coverage so i'm i mean they like their
West Coast players they stick with
Oregon here Amati somebody we expected
to come off the board maybe the fifth or
sixth round here
Seattle doesn't really care they'll go
get the players that fit their scheme
and this is another one of those guys
like Matt said maybe the traits are the
size profile doesn't seem like it but
the ability does yeah the Patriots
actually have back-to-back picks coming
up guys so we'll get to those really
shortly
Mela when we graded him for draft 400 I
compared him to Carl Joseph someone that
that maybe isn't just a starter fit out
of either safety position but a good
third safe I really like Ahmad ease
physicality he might be a little bit
undersized but he's not afraid to come
up and hit you I also really liked how
Oregon used him he's an exceptional
Blitzer from that corner position if
you're playing him and nickel he can
provide some pressure on the quarterback
not something you hear all the time from
a guy who plays corner safety mellow I
like you're wearing a blue shirt today
buddy because you're gonna want to
switch teams the New England Patriots
have drafted their quarterback of the
future
Jared Stidham as a New England Paige
what did I say on the show I just have
to change this logo yeah put a patriot
put Elvis on Melos chest he's ready to
go man they were all over him yeah all
over him throughout this draft process
not surprised at all obviously this is a
great fit and like I said in to be in
the show mellow be ready because they
got Nikhil here grading this now they
got Jared sidam that's great the new
Patriots found Tom Brady at 199 they
might have just found his successor boys
in the middle of the fourth round
jarrett Siddim from auburn started his
career Baylor transferred to Auburn no
help this year offensively but we've
seen Jarrett's did them in person the
traits are there guys is this the future
quarterback of the New England Patriots
I mean I'm not gonna go that far yet but
there's a lot to like with Jairus situm
he's got a lively arm he was one of the
best quarterbacks in practices down in
Mobile at the senior ball he's a good
athlete I think the decision-making can
be a little better at time
especially under pressure but like Matt
said and there you go you talk about the
deep ball with touch it's right there so
I think what Stidham they love the
traits they love the ability and they
love his commitment he's a guy that's
gonna come in sit down and learn behind
Tom Brady so I like to pick a lot I'm
simply giving it an a-minus because this
is a landing spot where he could sit for
a little while and learn yeah I can't
put enough pluses behind this pick it's
a plus plus plus plus if he had any
offensive lineman in 2018 he would not
be sitting here in round four of the
draft you watch this 2017 tape he looks
like a quarterback number one the
problem is he didn't have an offensive
line and if you've ever played
quarterback and you don't have an
offensive line you get scared and as
soon as you take that snap you start
looking at the guys who are breathing
down your neck you can't find your
receivers that's what happened with your
instead of in 2018 it's not gonna happen
with the Patriots there have already
built an offensive line
he has Tom Brady there this might be my
favorite pink of the draft because I'm
talking about him so much the New
England Patriots are making me look
smart they take my receiver one they
take one of my favorite quarterbacks
these guys are gonna hit and I'm gonna
look like a genius
thank you Bill Belichick mellows on the
desk oh that's have now a plus I do
think that this is a player he's a lot
like Jimmy Garoppolo players that we've
seen them target in the past I would not
be surprised guys if in three years time
when Tom Brady maybe finally retires if
Jared Stidham is your starting
quarterback for the New England Patriots
you thought it was Foster Marone you
were like I was I thought it was Foster
row and I was gonna be upset but now
what the turnaround here after they take
Foster Murrow I might just I might be
happy it was your comp for Jarrett's
Denham for Jared Stidham I know mine was
Derek Carr I thought I went car maybe
Dalton I think you were Dalton yeah so a
good player like someone we expected to
be a second-round pick and the Rams are
on the clock you just don't want to talk
about the Patriots get a quarterback
look at no I who said where he was going
at the dog show I mean there's so this
is so obvious like this is a perfect
landing spot for him I think at the end
of the day I have problems with Jared
Saddam's year I thought like Melo said
he had the deer and headlights look more
often than not which was a gigantic
issue but when it comes down to it this
is where you want him to go because he
has the talent to succeed tonight's time
I remember my
company you talk about derrick karr I
had David Carr another quarterback that
if you gave him any kind of support he
would have been good I don't even think
we can label David Carr a bust because
he was never given a chance to succeed
and in 2018 Jarrod Stidham didn't have
the chance to be successful on the
football field now he's gonna get that
with the New England Patriots
all right guys like Connor said the Los
Angeles Rams on there or on the clock
and the Atlanta Falcons have traded up
again for round four pick 33 so excuse
me I said the middle of round four cuz
time is not an essence in right now desk
we're flying we're getting to the end
around four so remember we will be here
round four and five breaking down every
pick and then Connor and I will be in
your app grading every team with draft
say that three times really fast it's
not easy so they are giving the rams
pick right now from the construction
site in LA where they're building the
stadium though cute yeah dudes wearing a
hard hat it's it's adorable so we'll
find out that pig the RAM the Rams are
taking the and it is gonna be great
gains in defensive lineman from
Washington Greg Gaines is a four by four
is what I would call him he's as wide as
he is tall ninety nine per Washington
but he is a powerful nose tackle yeah he
looks like he should be playing in
overalls at all times that's what Greg
Gaines reminds me of but he's a really
good football player you want to run
stuff for a guy that is hell-bent on
getting to where the football is he's a
lot of fun to watch so and you'll see it
right here I mean for a guy his size he
has really good closing speed I like it
look at the cans to get him in the goal
line overall hopefully he can use those
hands to to beat off some to get off
some blockers I like Greg Gaines I like
his game he can play nose tackle he
could play three tech he might be
athletic enough to move outside to the
five if you have that freedom when he
has beat a bear we're together on that d
line you could not get through the wall
they were there you're not getting
through it so I do think he's a nose
tackle put him next to Aaron Donald he's
gonna occupy the center he's gonna
control hopefully draw some double teams
so that Aaron Donald is not triple
teamed because teams now need eight
offensive linemen which is illegal but
Greg Gaines like when you see a fourth
round pick it's more about how does this
player fit into this team he can be a
rotational defensive especially short
yardage he can be a tube
we saw that on some of the clips guys
and the production was really impressive
seven and a half tackles for a loss for
and a half sacks for a dude that's six
one three twelve it's not easy for a
nose or a shade nose to have that kind
of production so I think with Greg games
you talk about the motor for a guy that
size it's really impressive I mean he's
good value here and for the Rams they
don't need guys that are three down
players right now they need players this
is your first and second down run
stopper third and short goal line
situation the Atlanta Falcons are gonna
go with a bit of a project here guys a
good athlete John Kaminski from
Charleston you can climb an edge rusher
you could call me defensive lineman he's
290 pounds but moved very very well some
of that we had heard a lot from area
Scouts were really high on this player
as a developmental guy so Atlanta gets
him at pick one 35 33 overall in round
four this is an area of need for them
we've talked about they have the small
pass rushers and big Beasley
tack McKinley they wanted to get someone
next to Grady Jarrett he could be a fit
here remember this is like a Seattle
style defense they value these guys that
are in the two 80s can bring some power
and speed I mean power and speed this is
somebody that plays almost at 290 pounds
and tested at under four 7:40 time and
right around a 7-3 cone so change a
direction and straight-line speed at
that size yeah we talked about him being
from a small school but this is the type
of player you want to roll the dice on
because traits galore and it fits that
old school kind of Seahawks defense that
they're bringing to Atlanta now you
don't know what you're gonna have with
your three tech maybe this guy puts on a
little bit of weight if not I think you
can play that edge position for them in
their defense and and develop out of a
small school once again yeah and they
they're very good at that they've been
good at finding some diamonds in the
rough there and I do you think scheme
fit for him it's really really important
and that's Connor alluded to when your
children 86 pounds and you were at a 469
in the 40-yard dash I don't care where
you went to school I'm gonna take a
chance on that to tap into that
potential
they love defensive linemen they're
Scott Pioli Thomas Dimitrov they're
really good at this and the Falcons have
not had a ton of picks guys because they
move up in round one they got Chris
Lindstrom they got Caleb McGarry they
fixed that offensive line now they start
adding some pieces on defense the
bengals have traded up guys to Round
four pick one
for 136 excuse me so it's 34 overall the
Bengals now move up they just saw Jairus
10 I'm coming off the board maybe and
they got Ryan Finley so I guess they
would not go course that was Dallas spot
so I think Dallas might have saw that
you know some of their identity so
whoever it may be was off the board and
you look at this trap I actually I'm not
a Ryan Finley fan but I like this draft
more than we've talked about Jonah
Williams just a rock-solid thick I know
Matt hates true sample but I don't he's
a very good player and Jermaine frat is
just a versatile yeah former safety but
he's a linebacker that can forward what
do you smell
what did you think of this trap is it I
don't know what the doc scurry I'm glad
that they went Jonah Williams because
they get that tackle and he is a tackle
I'm glad we can stop talking about that
and then drew sample is pretty much he's
an outside tackle he can block just like
anybody else on this in the draft and he
placed IED in so he can come in and
provide that run game support and
probably do a little bit pass catch you
know he's not an elite pass catcher
let's just be honest but he is an elite
blocker for the tight end position yeah
as a blocker Joe mix-ins offense from
their own yeah guys the bengals are
going with a shooting guard from north
carolina six-foot-six oh wait no not
that one they're going with Michael
thrown from Ohio State in offensive
guard again they go back to the big guys
in this trap Jonah Williams drew sample
now we see Michael Jordan I you get him
next to Billy price he played his best
football Ohio State when he was next to
Billy price he was someone the bengals
drafted in the first round last year so
maybe getting this tandem back together
works a little bit yeah and we've seen
the bengals you know tap into this ohio
state well quite a few times now so I
like this value here because Michael
Jordan was one of the best for me the
best interior offensive line left in
this trapping I mean he didn't get out
front and move and I know he did say
he's most comfortable at guard I like
the versatility and ability to play
Center I was gonna highlight that to
Connor I think that he can play center
he already has stepped in and played for
Billy price at Center before so he can't
provide guard and Center depth probably
not tackled but it could be an option if
you need him to but he can clear waste
were you running back yeah and that
seems to be what they're trying to do
good guys help Joe Mixon got Jonah he
got Michael Jordan drew sample like you
said Mel he got
tackle basically for the second round
withdrew sample just put ten pounds on
him let him play tackle the Oakland
Raiders around-the-clock then the
Philadelphia Eagles then we will be out
of round four don't forget you can send
in questions we will answer them just
hashtag them be our draft Connors
checking Twitter are amazing people back
in the control room or checking Twitter
so questions comments concerns send
those in hashtag BR draft if we can guys
let's take a look at the the big board
the best available player still
available Jonte Thompson is out there
Mac Wilson is out there
Kelvin Harmon Connors the one I wanted
to bring up yeah with you someone I know
you liked throughout the draft process a
big receiver a route runner
we saw his quarterback come off the
board to start today going to Cincinnati
Bengals tell them to Harmon a pretty big
surprise up yeah and Matt I know you
were lower on him than me but even 74
runs in this low but on pick one 37 yeah
I mean I understand this is a talented
wide receiver class but I don't
understand this kind of drop it's okay
Charleston mini Hugh 97 overall on the
board I know that you had told me
multiple times yeah I think you're too
wild Charles and many who he's not in
Connors top 10 available where are you
at on him as a player should he been
drafted in the fourth round no okay and
that comes from the Texas guy but I'm
not gonna be biased on him I don't even
know what kind of player he is we saw
one good year out of Charles a minute
you at Texas and that's just not good
enough for me if I'm a GM I'm not gonna
roll the dice on a guy just because he
has size he had one year of production
the other two years he struggled to get
on the field I don't think he's athletic
enough to really be a true edge player
like we talked about he's not big enough
to be an interior defensive lineman
either I think his best bet gained some
weight be an interior defensive lineman
he just doesn't have the bend and the
flexibility to be a true edge rusher
yeah and I think some of the the concern
with him is gonna be when people went
through Texas they heard he likes to
turn it on late in games he doesn't
always turn it on all the time in games
he really disappeared at times and I
think I bought into or didn't buy into I
fell into the trap that a lot of people
have the Senior Bowl we're talking about
him as a guy that could sneak into round
one and then you go watch the tape after
that and I don't see it so a man who was
not in my top 100 and this fall does not
even though it's the least bit
surprising thing to be in this draft
yeah 35 the Raiders 36 the Eagles
hopefully our buddy Adam left Co will be
happy with that pick
but yet sending those questions we
actually got one ride bass how do the
Giants look how does the Giants draft
look if they get Dante Thompson in the
fifth I on paper it looks good if you
get Deonte Thompson
there are obviously concerns here the
reason that he's still on the board you
have a small guy who I will say Clemson
exposed him they went at him to Clemson
offense
Melo's got Trevor Lawrence went out
there and went wears 14 okay that's
where we're going we're throwing at him
almost every play and it worked
yeah I look at this the Giants team just
get into that question when it comes
down to it you're always gonna talk
about the quarterback pick that's the
problem for the Giants but if that's the
guy they're rolling with and you just
look at every other pick in this draft
oh yeah I'll get to that in a minute but
he's gonna storm off against that in a
minute but when it cut and mi-24 to
today I am - you're two for two
congratulations yeah thank you yeah
keeping score at home there's some upset
people on that to my right here not me
honors have emotion for two the reason
being the Oakland Raiders with the 35th
pick in the fourth round have drafted
Melos favorite player Foster Murrow tied
in to LSU we're gonna great yeah I was
gonna ride high character rockin that 18
at LSU we've had him on the podcast he's
an exceptional leader a great Whistler
as well which is an underrated quality
mike Mayock goes back to the well with
another high character captain the
Oakland Raiders continue to impress the
boys on the desk
Foster Murrow a Titan from LSU physical
smart tough and a leader a captain
wearing that eighteen oh this is
phenomenal for the Oakland Raiders they
keep going back into the SEC and getting
productive football players with high
character and leadership Foster Murrow
here sneaky good athlete for his size of
the tight end position and man he could
block he's good as a pass catcher and he
can make things happen with the ball in
his hands after the catch I'm gonna let
my guy mellow here run away with this I
just want to give it an a-plus right
away it's an F - how am I supposed to
see Foster Murrow twice a year in the
silver and black I hate it he's a
complete tight end I thought he was
gonna be an exceptional run blocker
until I went to the senior vault and I
thought oh my god
this guy can really catch come
the replacement to Travis Kelce that is
a freaking Oakland Raider you know how
that feels as a fan you don't get you're
not a true fan but this would be like
Calvin Harmon going to the Patriots or
something like that I hate to pick up
mike Mayock once again doing an
exceptional job he's given an F -
because he's jealous this is one of the
best tight ends in the entire draft one
of the best people in the draft mike
Mayock in the Raiders they value
character leadership toughness Foster
Monroe checks every box the Raiders got
a guy that I compared to George Kittel
and tie it in now gonna be okay you know
walk it out you know hug I might I'm in
unit issue my hair - shoe you get
brought up here to Oakland
the Eagles closed out round four guy
Shareef Miller a good athlete you're a
Penn State yeah a long pass rusher at
defensive end so you didn't have a lot
of production therefore the Nittany
Lions but six four four six nine that
vertical jump is not impressive twenty
nine and a half I see a lot
what's your vert higher than that a lot
higher than that we should do it one day
I'm sick of football I'd like to see it
yeah I'm not doubting you I mean I've
seen the Instagram you know you got a
bird I just wonder what it was I think
when you look at Shareef Miller once
again he can be an explosive player the
production of Penn State was just okay
but at this point in the draft the
Eagles were clearly looking for outside
pass-rush help and this was one of the
better ones available there's some power
right there I mean yeah there is and
there's definitely he can convert that
and I thought he was a good tester
unfortunately you never really saw him
getting better at Penn State that was
one of my biggest concerns very even
across like he came in you're like man
it's an athlete like Heat we're gonna
watch him he's a name to know and it
just never really jumped to that next
level so it'll be interesting
I had him graded at 125 overall though
so I actually think this is exceptional
value for Philadelphia here hopefully
our guy left coast watching at home and
he's really happy with this pick guys
round five is starting the Arizona
Cardinals are back on the clock followed
by Jacksonville then Pittsburgh send in
those questions be our draft we will be
here with you for the duration of round
five and then open that be our app
Connor and I will be grading every
team's draft you'll get a new stick to
football episode Monday morning with our
recap of the entire draft as well and an
early look
you guys know I love this stuff the 2020
NFL Draft where actually I have mellows
big board in the show today my big board
too in the show today I would like to
get through 2019 like a normal
functioning human so I'm not showing you
my top twenty whatever players for 2020
dedicated to the game yeah I just can't
wait I find the next best thing and I'm
moving on it's it's a life motto for me
absolutely is moving on the Cardinals
around the clock guys in Deonte Thompson
finally comes off the board that we see
them go with they've really gone chalk
here they've taken best player available
at almost every pick the Cardinals have
so this is a good one I know we all
thought that he was going to be a top 65
player in this draft he falls here to
round five pick one this is really good
value yeah can we grade this yeah we're
in a great half of what I see at they'll
either kill it back through my book
after that Foster Moreau pick the
Arizona Cardinals continue to add
playmakers Deonte Thompson first team
all-sec at safety for Alabama guys
he's got range he can play center field
it's a little bit skinny he did have a
wrist injury which is why we see him
available here but I love the read and
react from number four it's weird that a
doubt you talk about range in ball
skills for Deion say Thompson he might
not be getting those cell phone breaks
that Kliff Kingsbury gives out because
he's got it he can get in the weight
room but he's a really really good
football player and at this point in the
draft the Cardinals continue to add
talent time and time again you see it
here cross field that's mine I
absolutely love that about his game this
is an A+ pick for that Cardinal
secondary yeah definitely agree with you
too and I think there was a knock on him
about maybe sighs maybe candy tackle I
think he shows a willingness to tackle
he just hasn't quite developed that yet
and maybe if he does put some weight on
put some strength on he can come in and
play downhill you got to replace some
safeties in this was probably my
favorite safety at least at one point in
the draft and you get him in the fifth
round congratulations to the Arizona
Cardinals great draft so far my comp for
him guys was Devin McCourty he is rangy
true center fielder which is harder to
find a college do you think I give it an
A+ Deonte Thompson was number 42 on my
big board the Cardinals steal him here
to start the fifth round great pick by
Steve time and cliff King clip Kingsbury
goodness
happening to the names here today the
Jags are on the clock now guys they're
making this pic from London England when
Oh rue warier gets picked I might have
to leave the video you gonna be upset
no I think no lead the video I'll leave
the video I can say that hey I'm trying
to help you out here yeah apparently
can't hear or talk now as we get into
the fifth round so 8 plus drafts for me
so far 3/8 plus drafts for me Bills
Raiders Cardinals yeah I think you could
add the Broncos in there too there we're
gonna be questions they're gonna be
close yeah we catch a lot of flack for
talking about the Chiefs all the time
but the rest of the AFC West is doing a
very good job in this draft too and John
Elway is the guy that we've talked about
maybe we don't love his drafts all the
time but I really think that they're
doing a very good job this year Oakland
Raiders maybe having the best draft I
think you guys will like this pick the
Jacksonville Jaguars getting running
back to maybe replace Leonard fournette
at least spell him Rick will arm step
from temple physicality is the name of
the game here man and he will run it you
over but he also has some breakaway
speed I don't know tell you a little
secret I liked him better than Alexander
Madison who went the photo yeah he does
have straight-line speed and you saw it
in the picture there I mean he hits his
triceps and biceps twice a week so you
got to love that with this guy but he is
a wrecking ball and he's one of those
players that listen he can handle the
rock 15 20 25 times a game you see the
production there so this is really
really good value in this spot Leonard
fournette has not been able to stay on
the field for multiple reasons so they
needed to depth in this area yeah and
you can address that in round five and I
really like Armstead I think that he can
come in and it'd be that other guy that
pushes Leonard fournette he's been with
the Jaguars and they never really had
the other guy like okay Yeldon supposed
to motivate me to be the starting
running back I think he comes in there
and he challenges for net I don't know
if the Jaguars are in love with him
we've already seen him get rid of some
guaranteed money in that contract so you
bring in a guy like Armstead in the
fifth round I think he's gonna get on
the field he's gonna play a lot in
Jacksonville next year for net could
miss some games and I think he can step
in and be that running I do really like
him I like sitting catch the ball a
little bit more but ground-and-pound
type runner between the tackles a
fantastic player the Pittsburgh Steelers
are all in the clock they traded up to
get Devin Busch they've had a good draft
guys across the board
we'll see where they go with this went
running back with their last selection
so it's been a fun pick for them
Deante Johnson from Toledo Melo that's
one of your favorite guys in this class
he really is he reminds me a lot of
Tyreke he'll maybe comes in as a gadget
guy from a small school in Toledo I know
he didn't run very fast but the game
speed is there the agility of the
shiftiness he can come in and be a
returner for the Steelers while being a
slot receiver and if the receiver if the
Steelers take a receiver late I'm gonna
bet on it to be a hit they've just
developed receivers - well there you
pair him up with another guy James
Washington who I think the Steelers are
very happy with and juju Smith's Shuster
he's pretty good at receiver - how would
you feel if they drafted a tight end
Heath Miller not there anymore they get
Zach Gentry from Michigan who was a
quarterback at one point I'm still kind
of built like one yes we have basically
seen the quarterbacks come off the word
Isaac Nauta is still out there but
excuse me the tight ends have almost all
come off the board is that Ginn tree
they get a big dude he's a power forward
so they lost Jesse James like think
about that this is kind of that same guy
big player and Shea Patterson did not
really utilize him well that's not shame
Patterson didn't utilize anyone well but
Zach Gentry here he does have some hand
issues you can see there how it kind of
cradles the ball I'd like to see him be
more of a hands catcher
especially with his wink that tied in
and just get your hands out there get
him on the ball and you'll probably make
that catch I think he can develop into
more of a blocker with his size he was a
high school quarterback he played tight
in at Michigan they shift in there so
he's still developing but jiminy
Christmas 6-8 to 65
that's an exceptional exceptional size
yeah big player you can't coach size
right because that what you say size is
a trait I mean you look at those traits
right there this guy might move to
tackle in a couple of years
it's insane this was a big need for them
they've checked a lot of boxes running
through this drives mean they got Benny
Snell Justin Lane Deante Johnson Devin
Bush and their needs were you know
really a corner linebacker safety wide
receiver tight end and they got a second
running back so they've done a very good
job here I think safety is the one area
we could see them go now in the sixth
round which we will not be here for pick
two in the sixth round belongs to the
Steelers so we've got these Seattle
Seahawks on the clock
a little hot and cold with their draft I
think a lot of reaches this pick is
Hot Potato by the way Detroit San
Francisco Giants now Seattle owns this
pick so we keep track of where these
picks originate no it's absolutely
insane but yeah I'm curious to see what
Seattle does here they have a specific
type at every position for their scheme
and they don't care about being you know
considered reaching yeah they took LJ
Collier in the first I wouldn't be
surprised by smaller pass rusher here
but the Giants who are on the clock at
five are going to take Ryan Connolly a
linebacker from Wisconsin so we're we're
a little bit ahead and actually see how
the Seahawks go linebacker and they stay
local Washington's VIN Burke Irvin one
of the most productive linebackers in
all of college football last year a
little bit undersized but very physical
and again incredibly productive he was
first team All pac-12 really between the
tackles guy who I think there's some
question about how well he plays outside
the hashes he finds the football that's
the most important thing to note what
Ben Burke Irvin I know we've talked
about on the show that he's one of those
productive players where we had some
questions about translating to the next
level but whenever he was put on the
field he found the football and that's
the most important thing for a
linebacker like him yeah in a high
character guy too they can come in and
be a leader that's what you want in that
Seattle defense
I like the player yeah I didn't know if
he would get drafted just because he was
a little bit undersized but I think
Seattle's okay with that as long as you
can find the football just like Connor
said you can find a spot on that Seattle
defense and I'm gonna keep like you said
pretending to be left Co you know he's a
free agent after this year Bobby Wagner
so maybe there's thinking about the
future linebacker depth here Bobby
Wagner wasn't that early of a pick so
yeah emember curvin will not be Bobby
yeah not gonna happen he was one of the
leading tacklers in college football
last year but that's a pretty high
standard to meet with Bobby Wagner
yeah good three cone time so we saw his
shiftiness his range short area
quickness so yeah two linebackers go
back-to-back we have Ben Burke Irvin
going to the Seahawks Ryan Connolly from
Wisconsin guys going to the Giants and
when I comp two - Nick vigil kind of a
taller linear linebacker I don't think
he had great speed or range but that was
constant defense we see Ryan Connolly go
before TJ Edwards at linebacker I think
that's a little bit of a surprise yeah
you're talking about straight-line
downhill kind of guy but I am really
shocked that he was picked over Edwards
and there's still some interesting
linebackers on the board here camps
myth the Mack Wilson slide is
unbelievable it is a little there's
ought to be something going on behind
there that's more than injury concerns
but if I just I don't know why we're
seeing him slide this far with other
linebackers being drafted in front of
him and even vote Sean Joseph to is
another guy that I like but to see Ryan
Connelly come off the board here I just
don't see the value here there are there
are probably 10 to 12 linebackers I
would have drafted before Ryan Connolly
but you know I'm not working in there
and I felt maybe they know something
that I don't I send text said why is he
following someone text me back because
he's not good at football so there you
go don't you love those answers yeah all
right thanks guys
appreciate that no library right and
then so I to people one person said it's
actually some medical with him so I got
to keep an eye on that
yeah Mac Wilson no medical character
maybe not the best football player so
Ian Rapoport NFL Network said Donte
Thompson was off several team sports
because of a degenerative knee condition
that explains his fall so it wasn't the
wrist that we thought it might be
because he had surgery missed the
combine it's actually a knee and it
makes you wonder if he knew about that
which is why he didn't test at the
combine and medical concerns are
something that aren't made you know
aren't there's not a lot of light shed
on them to the public but one thing I
found out yesterday too was and it's not
a serious concern but the reason Dawson
Knox did start to fall a little bit in
the third there was some medical
questions there nothing significant but
when you look at really good players
falling and there's not an explanation a
lot of times teams have something
concerning there yeah especially if it's
gonna be a problem that's gonna stay
with him throughout his career you don't
want to over reach and I will say that
this is being disputed by some some team
officials doctors that it was an injury
it's not generative so I think there's
there is a bit of an argument out there
but maybe this is why he felt whether
it's warranted or not but if teams
believe that an injury could be
long-term or you know keep a guy off the
field or shorten his career we've seen
jji fall we've seen good players fall in
the past because of that the
Indianapolis Colts are up followed by
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers than the
Detroit Lions guys so the Colts like
Melo said if Chris Ballard drafts you
we're probably gonna be pretty big
believers on what you can do as a
football player so we'll see what
direction they go here and it actually
will be safety Marvel tel from USC
so a big safety love that six foot two
two hundred pounds they're betting on I
think some athletic upside here with
Margaret tell who I thought was better
in 2017 than it was in 2018 which you
can say about everyone at USC basically
but for six-speed that is the concern
Marvel tell but I'll say this coverage
potential in terms of backpedal and
helping over the top and coming down
hill and tackling is phenomenal so this
is exactly where we expect them to be
picked but I'll say this I had them as a
top ten safety in this class so I'm
finally feel like I'm back in the good
graces of crisp a learning company yeah
it's interesting because I think he's
more of a free safety than a strong
safety that down cooker bubbling cooker
has been hurt a little bit so maybe we
see here a depth safety something that
can hopefully play on special teams but
that dude is not a bad player you see
number seven their awareness finds the
ball kind of right place right time
needs to tuck that football way though
my gosh I'm not running out you see that
but he does have some ability in the
open field mellow I really like him too
I think has a lot of range good
instincts you can come up and you can
play against the run - so the Colts get
another piece to that defensive
secondary there is it it's gonna be very
good and like you said the Colts drafted
guy I'm gonna give it a great grade so
if we're grading this when it would be
an A+ just because it's Colts pick I
don't care who they take I happen to
like marvel tell but I think it's a
great selection for them in the fifth
round thank eyes we have a big one we
got a surprise you love these picks have
run away with it absolutely love this
pick Utah is now special teams you in
the NFL Matt gay the kicker from
the Utes going to the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers did you learn nothing from
Roberto Aguayo did you learn anything
Jason light what are you doing man why
are you trapped in a kick her in the
fifth round you need a backup
quarterback it's not great and he's I
actually think he's a good kicker
prospect I want to make that clear you
don't take a kicker here no well he's
got a big leg I just he better he does
stomp it he does we want to talk about
the player he does have a big leg but I
just I question the light not back in
the giraffe room so my question is
follow through on his kicks I think that
could lead to some accuracy issues at
the next level and all of that is
completely made up I have no no I
wouldn't draft one in the fifth round
yeah I mean yeah you can't even point to
the athleticism here because
not the combines so he did make he made
26 field goals last year he's a kickoff
specialist apparently we did have some
notes on him
58 touchbacks so big leg big leg big
legs Matt that's the key now some people
probably have a touchback right now so
return games not even an option yeah he
was the Lou Groza Award winner in 2017
hey you missed on Aguayo you got to get
a guy who I mean he only he connected 72
72 percent of his kicks over 50 yards so
you know that on the big leg toner all I
did I ate you we're gonna hire you to
scout that was one of two kickers I
watched this year the other being called
Tracy yeah Jose and we saw him at the
Senior Bowl who also made some big kicks
there so the board in the fifth round
which is fantastic and then the Detroit
Lions are on the clock followed by the
bills Niners Cowboys hashtag be our
draft if you have questions about
players who are still on the board there
are still some guys Mack Wilson we
talked about falling due to medical
maybe character as well as team's not
being as impressed with his place of the
Alabama linebacker still out there
Kelvin Harmon still available bo Shawn
Joseph a linebacker from Florida Joe
Jackson John Dre Walker some edge
rushers from the almost of sec from the
southeast both of those to Miami and
Georgia so there's still some talent out
there in round five guys yeah I mean
there definitely is in Tyree Jackson
there's a guy that I really thought was
going to go much earlier in this draft
I thought teams would bet on that up
side that he has him and just haven't
seen him come off the board yet people
talked about the Lions addressing that
quarterback knee maybe he is a guy that
we could see right here very strong arm
much like Matt Stafford yeah and again
teams have not been on traits I know
that's been something we talked about a
lot Deacon Matt calf bell we haven't
seen the trait based guys teams really
fall in love with that yet so man
congrats to University of Utah though to
special teams like you told us had two
specialists drafted before Texas has had
a player drafted
we are not back we're not back Lawrence
definitely now punter and kicker from
Utah before a Texas player thank you
Charlie Strong we appreciate I mean
Kevin Hart was my favorite wide
receivers and two specialists were taken
before
so we're all sitting here yeah yeah if
you would have told me at any point even
coming in today to today that Mack
Wilson would be on the board but we
don't have kicker number one and punter
number one on the board P 1 told you
you're crazy K 1 K 1 I'm waiting for a
long snapper just to round this out we
hit the trifecta and this kicker better
be an all-pro or I know what you're
doing yes have to find a new team the
Lions pick is in we're waiting to hear
on that the bills we'll pick after them
I know Tyree Jackson has a really close
relationship with Josh Allen and
obviously very familiar with the Buffalo
area that would be fun if they kept him
there I mean like Anthony Johnson his
receiver is still on the board he would
be a good fit there yeah yeah he's a
high floor player at this point of the
draft in my view so the Detroit Lions
okay they've had a I think a quiet draft
for Detroit but a lot of players that
we've liked that have come through there
so the Lions addressing a lot of needs
like this was more need based drafting
for them they had TJ Hawkinson they a
Jelani to vie will Harris maybe two
reaches in round two and round three
we'll see where they go here to start
off pick eight in round five so they've
drafted I think they have a type like
every player they've drafted is a tough
player will Harris for physical safety
we've raved about TJ Hawkinson for
months and months as the tight end
prospect
I still think one of the best tight ends
that I've ever evaluated from especially
a three down standpoint he can really do
everything and we got another one here
from Richard royal hashtag be our draft
how long until the Patriots pick david
sills or hunter Renfro oh yeah today's
the day Pro watch is on I just want to
make that clear forever you know I
honestly think those two guys have some
of the best hands of this time whoa if
you can throw the ball close to them
they're gonna catch it it's not gonna be
a focused drop issue with either one of
them hunter Renfro has tiny tiny little
hands I don't know how he catches the
football thing but it's almost every
single time the ball is around him in
national championship games in the ACC
he can catch the football I would love
to see him go before we're off the desk
here by the end of round five
yeah anyone with a hairline like that
we're gonna celebrate game draft into
that he'll catch the ball out of the
slot he'll fix your computer just get
this guy in the building he'll find a
need and
Philip yeah so the Bills have drafted
bowshot Joseph we don't know that Lions
pick yet but the bills take motion on
Joseph he finally comes off the board
we'll see what that Lions pick is so we
jump ahead a little bit here guys as we
wait for the lion someone's playing
drums on TV I don't know what's
happening yeah so we'll find out that
pick Kelvin Harmon remains the best
player on the board after Mack Wilson
most of the top 100 is decimated right
now I will say that which is always a
good sign when you get to one yes 145
you want a lot of your top 100 gone so
it feels good to be at least in that
range we've got a couple guys drafted
who didn't play special teams that
weren't Wes Martin Quincy Williams
weren't ranked but have been drafted yep
so the lines have made their pick here
it is Imani over warier oh there we go
Thank You Connor here we go
the pick was really in Matt Justin well
I know the Lions are taken here we'll
just have to move on
skip it probably no big deal good value
here I think with over warrior you were
looking at you know early in the year a
lot of people felt like he was a second
round corner there are some serious
concerns there about long speed but you
talk about beating somebody up at the
line of scrimmage this guy can do it but
turning and running down the field now
that's an area where bad throw but he
still made the play on it
I like him in a press scheme I really do
give him some help over the top and he
could flourish what do you guys I liked
him I thought he makes a big place in
big moments he's not twitchy that's the
big thing I mean when you looked at the
testing times I had him ranked as a
third round player because I liked his
physicality I didn't think he played 447
which is what he tested at I think you
have to watch that mellow this is
someone that you pointed out at one
point it may be late season that you
liked their technique though yeah and I
think if you run a zone heavy scheme you
can go ahead and take him you see he can
come up any place against the run well
he can't turn his hips and run it's
gonna be a problem and that's why he's
available in round five and not around
two or three if we could see that
flexibility in the fluid hips he would
be a higher draft pick but that's what
he needs to work on other than that I
mean I really like him six to 205 ish
physical corner we see him have ball
production he can come and he can tackle
good pick for the team here in the fifth
round yeah alright we've got the
remember the bills took Bosh on Joseph
very active tackler I do you want to
talk about him because I add him as a
top 100
played all over the field when you watch
Florida 11 was often the guy making the
plays for them so it was having sack
production good range can time the snap
and he had a hit on Jake from in the
Georgia game where you're the okay like
the bow shots here to play ninety three
tackles has past year incredible
production
yeah the flashes were lb you know three
or four tight lashes the problem is the
consistency with him so in terms of
being a good athlete I think there's
definitely a role from at the next level
if he can be coached up to be a little
more consistent that talent is there you
see the closing speed and even that turn
to get to the quarterback is very very
impressive and I think size is gonna be
another issue for him there you seem hit
Jake from like you were talking about he
weighs in at 230 that doesn't look like
a 230 pound linebacker to me he looks
like he's about 215 where I've said
before I thought maybe he was even a
safety the first couple times I thought
it was a box safety but they're gonna
play him at linebacker I don't know that
he's strong enough to be a true Mike
linebacker but he can play that off ball
linebacker give you some coverage
support I like the pick in round 5 who
athletes they got Tremayne Edmonds they
have Oh Sean Joseph you compared him I
said to Jordan Hicks so he's gonna be
able to turn and playing some coverage
and they they're getting pre athletic
for Sean McDermott's defense which they
really felt what he did at Carolina with
Thomas Davis Luke Kuechly Shaq Thompson
they like athletes the linebacker
I mean tremendous ya know but they they
definitely are taking athletic front
seven players across the board there I
did have my pronunciation guide up for
the Penn State corner so I just wasn't
ready for it I don't notice we're
waiting so the Niners are on the clock
this is part of the Dakota Watson trade
he went to Denver the Niners get this
pick 10 overall in the fifth round just
don't take another punter that's all I'm
asking well while we're waiting let's
get to one more here from B yard hashtag
be our draft this from our guy Eric
which DB Oro line should Carolina's
draft with their fifth round pick or
should they be the team to take a shot
on Kelvin Harmon you know yeah they
should be keep him in state but David
Edwards from Wisconsin is still out
there as an offensive tackle like to
play right tackle for you so I would
look at him as a pretty good fit for
what they're doing I know they've
they've addressed some offensive line
needs but I would keep going back to
that well especially if there's not a
BPA on the on the board for them and
this feels like a little bit of a slide
for Dennis Daly right
a tackle yeah I mean I know he wasn't
gonna be a second or third round player
but the offensive line run came early
and no yeah I really
I expected him to go probably around
four I don't know what he's exactly the
best name of the draft so far amazing
yeah Niners then Raiders and Packers
then dolphins the Niners are letting a
kid make the pick that's actually pretty
cool we should do that which I hate it
you don't like it okay I just I don't I
want to watch the draft that's why I
watch it here on the BR stream I know
that we can see the rest of the
television I don't need it I don't need
some kid telling me I just want to hear
the analysis of the page well the Niners
have taken a linebacker let's analyze
this picked Dre Greenlaw from Arkansas
80 tackles six and a half roll loss he
was a three-year start four-year starter
I think actually they're an incredible
production for Arkansas who not a very
good team but Drake Greenlaw I think
fits the mold of what the Niners one
this guy is not that different from who
we saw them draft little third round
last year Fred Warner at BYU yeah
unfortunately that defense was on the
field a lot which might have led to the
high production numbers and I think this
is you know there's still some talented
linebackers on the board but I
understand the depth here this is
probably somebody you're looking that's
tough and complacent Eames yeah I have
questions with his ability to tackle I
saw a lot of missed tackles I saw a lot
of running backs to be able to run
through him and gain extra yardage I
think that maybe the Niners are just
like it we don't care about that anymore
you bring in Quan Alexander's kind of
like having issues I are you drafted a
guy that you just signed so if that's
your mold for linebacker that's what you
want I think he can get to the football
he just struggles when once he gets a
yeah my comp for him was Dale Buchanan
so kind of a smaller athletic linebacker
guys
the Raiders pick is in and I want to
drop this nugget on you thanks to our
buddy Adam Schefter the Antonio Brown
trade is now complete the Raiders got
Antonio Brown the Steelers get John say
Johnson and Zach Gentry so hell of a
trade guys yeah we'll see the Johnson
picks interesting I do like Deante
Johnson it's hard to replace a guy who
was probably going to be a hall-of-famer
and at one point was the best receiver
in the entire league but I bet Deante
Johnson doesn't cause any problems in
that locker room at least not like what
we were seeing this all yellow
moustaches Beyonce Johnson would be
funny if you showed up with one anyway
I'm gonna do that for the tailgate tour
who's gonna die my mom whatever school
right
that's the Mustang keeping the questions
going Tyler furnace one of our best
listeners to stick to football hashtag
PR Draft was a good landing spot for
Gerald Willis the third maybe the
Vikings dude man he's a good player the
flashes are phenomenal when Gerald
Willis and he got I mean he worked very
hard see after he got kicked off Florida
was on the scout team Miami in 2017 had
a fantastic year in 2018 this is the
point in the draft where he's a steal
because I think if you get him on the
field in those passing situations on the
interior he's somebody that can fly to
the football and really cause havoc
against the quarterback yeah you
mentioned getting kicked off Florida
might be why he's still available the
Raiders guys actually traded up I missed
that I'm sorry they traded with the
Cowboys so they give up 158 and 218
overall to get here to 149 so the
Raiders are on the clock they just took
Foster Monroe that's why Melo is still a
little bit depressed and they are gonna
take boys hunter-reay throw like a
receiver from Clemson I need little tiny
hands but this guy can catch every
football I really like the Raiders draft
and what they're doing here play him in
the slot with guys like Antonio Brown
amazing gonna be a very good target for
David Carr guys we're gonna grade this
video obviously like Melo sets do it he
could play slot you can fix your
computer you can sell you insurance yeah
I love Hunter in for it let's do this
place the stickiest hands in the draft
now belong to the Oakland Raiders
yep that's actually a college football
receiver Hunter Renfro number 13 go to
the Raiders at the top around five guys
we've joked about hunter Renfro because
yes he looks like your IT guy but he
catches everything thrown his way dirt
cars got a safety though yeah those
sticky icky hands are coming to Oakland
and I absolutely love them fit I mean
this guy catches everything he's a
pretty good route runner and here you
see it none of this was small the three
cone will impress you that is his name
at his game change of direction for
Hunter Renfro so you look at it here in
this offense he's gonna have plenty of
space to work with they went out and got
a premier running back in Josh Jacobs
they have Antonio Brown now hunter
Renfro who's gonna be your third down
conversion kind of guy this is an a for
me throughout yeah I'm right there with
him too if you just look at hunter
Renfro you'll say there's no
in hell this guy is a football player
but you'll watch him on the field and
you're like holy hell this guy is a
football player right because he can
catch everything he's dominates out of
the Slaton underneath great pic here for
the Raiders I love it I'm giving it in
there mike Mayock you're doing a really
good job man great draft for them
another high character players who
proved himself in huge games watch the
college football playoffs last three
years Simon Renfro who is at Clemson for
a decade made the biggest plays there
down the field in the slot this is a
Danny Amendola type wide receiver for
Derek Carr the Raiders keep getting it
done great pick by mike Mayock
this Raiders draft if we look at what
they've taken so far they're getting
guys that are proven winners already
that are gonna come in and contribute
we've talked about Ozzie Newsome and his
Alabama ties mike Mayock have like a man
crush on Clemson players what is going
on here why wouldn't you I mean you have
a crush on Dabo Swinney so why not have
a crush on all those players man I mean
be they can beat Alabama there's only
team they've been dominant why not tap
into that well and get those high
character dudes like Cleveland furl
Trayvon Mullin and the three players who
made the biggest plays in the national
championship game they just got them I
mean they might get Trevor Lawrence into
oh my gosh yeah good lord and here's
something interesting John Gurdon
generally doesn't love playing rookies
when it comes out he's drafting guys
that aren't real rookies they're all
players that have played for a long time
Cleland Ferrell won two national
championships is really a three-year
productive starter at clemson Josh
Jacobs somebody who's been a part of
that backfield at Alabama for a long
time so you and then Jonathan Abram I
mean he's played all over the place
hunter Renfro has literally made
national title winning catches so when
it comes down to it Jon Gruden and mike
Mayock I really like the dynamic they
have working together to find impact
Talent guys I want to read the Raiders
draft to you which I know sometimes just
reading a list isn't the best thing ever
but Cleveland referral Josh Jacobs
Jonathan Abram Trayvon Mullen max Crosby
Isaiah Huston foster Murrow and Hunter
Renfro that is a lot of pics number one
but they also got Antonio Brown out of
the strap like we just talked about this
is a phenomenal haul this is a team
building all for the Raiders and I say
this if you're a cheap spam if you're a
Broncos fan if you're a Chargers fan you
better be afraid of the Oakland Raiders
right now this is a team two years ago
they were making runs Derek Carr was an
MVP candidate before he got hurt so I
would not sleep on what they're doing in
Oakland no as the Chiefs fan it's
concerning what they're doing because
the only pick that I would even question
is Crosby and I like that selection in
the later rounds to get a guy that's a
developmental everybody else is probably
going to play a lot early on for the
Raiders and they're gonna develop some
things over the next four years with all
these draft picks guys there anybody
Packers pick is in they went with a
defensive end for their three-four
scheme
Kingsley kiki from Texas A&M I had him
rated at 134 overall okay I think can
play a little bit of everywhere seven
sacks last year yeah 4:00 a.m. for the
Aggies really productive in the SEC item
at 1:10 so I love the value here I think
you see the size they are sure that the
speed and everything with the testing is
just ok but he has the length to live
out on the edge set the edge and of
course he's done it before the
production is there you really love that
number 11 tackles for a loss I think
this is somebody that could be a very
very productive run defender that Mike
Daniel's role that they have in Green
Bay he fits in just perfectly with that
yeah and again the athleticism I think
is a testing wasn't great I thought the
tape was better so good short area
quickness for him the Dolphins are on
the clock then the Falcons and the
Redskins we got a question from Anthony
Medina Connor probably for you
could you see Darren Lee and a pick go
to the Raiders for Rodney Hudson the
Jets need a center the Raiders need a
linebacker I mean there's a relationship
there between teams you saw in the
colitis Emily trade so far so that
wouldn't shock me I know there's been
some rumors some fake emails as well
about Darren I do expect Darren Lee to
be moved today would be very bizarre if
they don't with you know he hasn't been
at ot a so far and that might be the
team's decision we're not really sure so
Darren Lee I'm not sure if Lee be a
player for a player Trey Duke Johnson is
another name to keep an eye on maybe
they could find some kind of swap there
yeah all right guys the Miami Dolphins
at 13 I've taken a Wisconsin linebacker
Andrew Van Ginkel someone who when I
talk to Scouts the last summer they were
very high on him just didn't put it
together this past year 2018 but Van
Ginkel
might play linebacker I know some teams
have thought of him as maybe an edge so
we could see him be gonna be a versatile
linebacker in round five who can add
some depth and a good athlete at that I
think
the most important things to note here
with Van Ginkel so I mean you talk about
sub 7/3 kkona 38 very he's somebody that
you're not really gonna grade the film
the same because you feel you can get
more out of him with his testing times
yeah in another Wisconsin linebacker
comes off the board before it CJ Edwards
is very surprised he has to be a concern
there speaking of guys I've never seen
this before the Dallas Cowboys have
asked Tristan Hill who is their top pick
this is according to the the Dallas Fort
Worth star-telegram Star Telegram excuse
me they've asked Tristan Hill to sign a
work ethic clause in his contract so we
mentioned he didn't play a lot this past
year at UCF we were kind of critical the
coaching staff for keeping their best
player off the field the Cowboys are
apparently gonna insure themselves
against him so probably gonna be some
clauses in there the he I'll show up to
workouts make sure he hits meetings on
time is this is the first you've ever
heard of something he never heard I'm a
little surprised NFL PA would allow it
on us yeah on a rookie deal this seems
like something that would happen with a
veteran guy that you're taking a chance
on not a guy that you're gonna be your
first overall selection for the Dallas
Cowboys it's very interesting but that's
pretty coaching staff turnover probably
just destroyed this guy in interviews
they wouldn't put him on the field right
and probably destroyed him in all
interviews with teams yeah let's take a
look at the best available players I
have two of my top 75 still left on the
board so if your team is coming up give
me good news for you Mack Wilson else
out there Kelvin Harmon available Joe
Jackson a andre walker
Roger Walker missed some time throughout
this process with it an injury David
long junior a little bit of an
undersized linebacker there's some
talent here though guys I can find a
role for each of these players on a team
Oh without a dad I mean the one that
surprises me honestly is a Manuel hall
just because teams reach on speed all
the time I think that one is very
interesting in this spot
yeah we're sitting at like a round pick
150 or so you see a Manuel Hall right
there at 91
I thought teams would reach for that
long speed that he has to be that deep
threat and we just haven't seen it
happen yet now I'm a little surprised by
Joe Jackson because he fits that mold of
like a big end 275 pounds that that
feels like a need especially in this
draft there weren't a lot of teams or
excuse me a lot of players that fit them
no we saw a lot of 245 250 players yeah
he's a true for three defensive end who
had
pretty good production at Miami yeah I
thought after Collier went off the board
then the team's looking for a similar
role might look for Jackson and when I
saw him against Florida same person the
power is very very evident didn't expect
them to be a day one or two pick
nonetheless right but still somebody
that can come in and find a role like
you said Matt yeah I thought late round
three early round four was gonna be the
spot for him so the Atlanta Falcons are
on the clock that pick will be coming in
very soon then we have the winners of
the draft may be other than Oakland the
Washington Redskins at pick 15 in this
round so we're getting close to halfway
through guys to find a way through to
round five teams still get good players
our buddy George Hilliard chimes in hash
IBR draft the hill things kind of a
missing headline Cowboys defensive
coordinator says he requires it from all
his defensive linemen so it might be
more of like I remember those you'd sign
this contract in high school like I will
not drink I will not do drugs
I might play football right yeah Randall
Floyd sign maybe it's like that maybe
Rod Marinelli is like I'm gonna need you
to sign this paper and not go by those
Aerosmith Tickets with NASA but kind of
go to their Smith's concert yeah Randall
Pink Floyd thank you I think he's on to
something here this is something that
kind of old-school coaches will do then
you say you're gonna sign this contract
that you are gonna show up to everything
it's probably not like written into his
actual rookie contract this is more of a
team thing that they're gonna make him
sign and you better do those things if
you're gonna play for Robin Mary
Marinelli ya rabb mare no he's
straight-up old-school another really
good one here from Logan host who is
someone that you guys were high on that
might slide into the late 7th or UDF a
category ooh
that's yeah I mean I think we're looking
at trial so many huge sliding right now
of why and I was a super high on him but
high enough guys let's get to the
Falcons picked
cadre Tolleson the running back from
Pitt so ok so physical backing yeah and
some of that I I questioned I wasn't
sure if he was actually drafted bolide I
thought he was a scheme fit type player
not not a go-to running back so getting
him
I think obviously we see 6-foot tall 228
pounds they want a little thunder to go
a Devonta Freeman in the back fit and
I'll say this my 8th 9th and 10th
overall running backs are still on the
board here you know 1 through 7 are long
long gone but Quran higdon Rodney
Anderson Dexter Williams we're still
waiting to hear those names come off the
board here he might see a little time
like a
back role too you know like yeah not a
true running back now for short yardage
a big thumb where they can come in there
right it in spell as a number-two
running back to you already have your
guy that can catch the ball out of the
backfield so go ahead and provide some
depth that running back that's what
they're doing right now I'm gonna lie
the 31 ranked he was my number thirty
one ranked running back in this year's
class so didn't know speed I mean it's a
460 I who didn't couldn't create
laterally which is always a concern when
you see a big back you want them to at
least be able to move left or right to
miss that first tackle he didn't do a
whole lot of yeah and I think over the
last couple of years we've averaged
around 23 24 running backs going per
giraffe so 31 not expected to usually be
drafted no undrafted free agent great
from us so that is the pick for Atlanta
guys that the Washington Redskins around
the clock and cannot say enough good
things about the draft that they've had
so far namitha Wayne Hoskins Montez
sweat scary Terry Terry McClaren if
you're not in on there's the nicknames
that we just threw out for people
they've had a really good draft checking
a lot of boxes so far you look at those
three right there I mean the Montes
sweat fall it's not shocking but it's
still tremendous value and I like that
they were aggressive to go get him this
football team is fascinating to me right
now because it's no joke that the NFC
East is very very tough especially with
the Eagles and Cowboys in there yes the
Giants are going through a little bit of
a rebuild right now but people forget
before Alex Smith got hurt last year
this team was winning the NFC East and
I'm not saying Dwane Haskins can come in
and be that right away that's a lot to
ask
yeah but they had the talent to win a
lot of football games next year it all
starts at the quarterback position and
they didn't have Darius guys last year
great boy should be healthy this year
that was running back number two with
not a very far gap behind sake one last
year we've really liked his game and if
he can provide some things this year for
your team that's gonna be a very good
team in it if Haskins can do almost
anything they can contend for the NFC
East as crazy as that sounds I know they
had a bad year but you're right Connor
they they were very good before that
injury
yeah very good so we'll see what they do
they had a bryce love so and then Wes
Martin a player that we didn't have
ranked or I didn't have ranked at least
I'm gonna speak for the whole desk so
maybe a reach at a position of need
there we'll see where they go here I
would actually love to see them go back
to the secondary a little bit tap into
some of the value at corner Michael
Jackson from Miami is out there Chris
Boyd from
exes maybe get a bigger corner and those
two both tested fairly well so I would
like to see them address that area here
I mean obviously they have Josh Norman
there okay at one corner spot but I
would keep trying to add to that
secondary a little bit yeah and I think
as we get closer here we talked about
the Panthers earlier we would like to
see them be one of those seems to take
the shot on Kelvin Harmon I think that
would fit for them with their receivers
get a big target for Cam Newton not this
slide for harm and I didn't expect him
to be a first or second-round pick but
this is a bit rich for me I I think if
he falls to the right place he could be
the steal what is more surprising for
you the Mack Wilson or Kelvin Harmon so
what Mack Wilson I had heard that the
coaches did not say the greatest things
about him so that's not too surprising
here but I mean this class did not have
a lot of linebackers so I know somebody
would reach on him
what Kelvin Harmon it's a good wide
receiver class so of course he was gonna
fall but I mean everybody loves Ryan
Finley so much watch how many plays
Kelvin Harmon bails him out over and
over again it's just fascinating to me
how we talk so much about the
quarterback when it's the wide receiver
and you want to go back to 2017 Kelvin
Harmon had one of the best performances
against that Clemson secondary that we
saw from a wide receiver yeah is when
you have Eric flower starting on your
offensive line you got to make some
changes and they do
Ross Pierce bakker depict the center
from Alabama it's funny because you talk
it like when you watch him you actually
come up with all the cliches like man
this dude's pretty and he's like really
tough he doesn't move exceptionally well
but Ross Pierce Parker but could get in
there Tracey chase truly a was a sixth
round peg 2017 he's our starting center
Pierce Parker is a good player in the
middle of this scheme know he can outrun
a 40-yard dash don't ask him to make me
run down screens 40 yards down the field
I think he's incredibly strong at the
point of attack though just snap the
ball and don't move but there you see
the leverage right there and the ability
to drive at his size it's very very good
yeah and I really like him too I think
the Redskins keep winning this draft we
look at this highlight package you've
seen him at Center you've seen him at
left guard so far plug and play out of
Alabama once again yeah Cody white hair
with my comparison for him team captain
which that's hard are you at Alabama
that is not easy to show you got some
candidates yeah there's some good
players and again he is just tough in
the middle if they want to like you said
Melo they get Darius guys back they
would establish the run
they want to open up some play action
for Dwayne Haskins this is a great way
to do it and I love when a team does
this when you draft a quarterback and
then immediately
we're not immediately but in the same
draft get a center just let these two
grow up together a little bit exactly
and you want your Center to be the
leader the team captain you look at a
player like Pierce Walker who's worked
with Jalen Hertz and then to a very very
young - etana bi-lo in a tough situation
now he's going into a situation where
Dwayne Haskins is gonna ask to be the
guy eventually I love pairing them two
together and scary Terry - so a fun core
building in Washington yeah it is and
they've done a good job I mean the West
Martin picked surprised me but if you
had said Pierce bakker was gonna go in
around 4:00 and West Martin was gonna go
out around 5:00
I think that's the biggest surprise ever
so the pig is in for the card for the
Panthers will have that shortly the
Browns come back on the clock probably
another corner at the rate that they're
going that greedy Williams Sheldrick red
wine the Broncos are up then maybe
Connor you're near Jets and we heard we
talked about it earlier the Browns would
be one of those teams we think willing
to take a gamble on Preston Williams so
that watch is on his yellow - that'd be
those receivers with Preston with that I
would actually be ok with him in that
locker room because Jarvis Landry is
such a great leader he is yeah you know
he's gonna get everybody's act together
he'll yell at you in the in the locker
he doesn't care about his contagious
yeah the Carolina Panthers go running
back guys give Christian McCaffrey a
little bit of help Jordan Scarlett
running back from Florida more physical
than he then he looked he's 500 208
pounds but he will run between the
tackles a bad bad Florida Gators team
this past year he was really the meat
and potatoes of that offense getting
everything going so I liked Jordan
Scarlett I think yes enough run away
speed at his size and again
battle-tested in the SEC was pretty
productive this past year
yeah we've been watching him for a
couple years now and I think the talent
is actually pretty good and he's not
somebody that's gonna test
off-the-charts to change the direction
and all of that but I think he has the
straight line speed and he's gonna be
somebody that can provide some depth of
their running back spot yeah and I think
that's what it is I mean depth at the
running back spot this is a guy that we
thought might come out earlier in the
draft if everything at Florida would
have worked out for him - but I like
that they're filling needs within the
offense I know that you have Cam Newton
you have Christian McCaffrey but you
still need to fill those death spots and
that's a great spot to do it guys we
talked about the Cleveland
it's not being afraid to roll the dice
on character right we all agree with
that
well they do here Mack Wilson linebacker
Alabama comes off the board
number 56 overall on my board by far the
best player left fluid athlete we're
gonna grade this pick fella so get ready
for that but Mack Wilson goes to
Cleveland they've done a great job John
Dorsey has of just letting the board
fall no panic so we'll grade this pick
Mack Wilson goes John Dorsey gets a
middle linebacker of the future maybe
over the right now Mack Wilson from
Alabama a player many believed would be
a round to pick falls a little in this
draft guys maybe some character concerns
maybe some injury concerns I think he's
a hell of a player that the Browns
stealing around five yeah I think the
value here is exactly what you want
obviously a ton of playing experience
this year on a high level defense and I
think what Mack Wilson you like his
ability to move seek out screens the IQ
before the snap and you'll see it right
here you've been in coverage a little
bit so he's a decent athlete put some
ball skills when it comes down to it for
the Browns they're not afraid to take on
players like this where I think some
scouts have questions about overall
toughness along the lines of that so I
give this a B I think the value here is
right this is where you want to roll the
dice I'm not expecting Mack Wilson to
come in and be a starter on that defense
but somebody that provides us a good
backup yeah and this is around five I
mean b-plus year I don't know why he's
fine I would give it a higher grade if I
understood that a little bit more so I
think there's something to that but to
get a number three linebacker for me in
this spot is a great value I really like
the pick I like what they're doing in
Cleveland you get another guy from a
very tough SEC defense who's been with
physical offenses he's proven himself he
can pull the chain at linebacker and
come fill rushing lanes all these great
things you're not giving these great
grades I'm going to I'm gonna give it a
pleasure and easy 56 overall you just
got him at like 155 you got him 100
picks too late watch and learn
Cleveland Browns fans John Dorsey knows
what he's doing so to LA Wolfen Alonzo
Highsmith another great pick for your
Cleveland Browns
I don't know that matt has AC in his
green no I was giving him out last night
I got to see in here somewhere
see I have a seat see their depth
alright you are the c+ you can even
right
yeah I gave nf- yesterday I believe so
the Broncos are on the clock guys this
pic has traveled a little bit and it is
Justin Holland's and edge rusher from
Oregon comes off the board before Jalen
jelkes yeah I think a lot of folks liked
more or a bigger name at least
but Justin Holland's tested very well
throughout this process gets his name
called here in round five in Oregon they
have some pieces on that defense to it
and he's another one very long pass
rusher also has experience at linebacker
and as a pass rusher obviously I would
have went somewhere else I don't like
that pick but maybe they do yeah I mean
this is a little early for him I had him
in second round six round seven type
player compared him to shylack Calhoun
but he's six five to forty five guys and
ran a for five flat so you're taking a
chance on athleticism here not the
biggest need they'd have a couple good
pass rushers out there that you guys
probably heard of I think the thought
with Hollins is on third down you can
play him in the box and have the
disguise of him rushing the passer
actually drop him into coverage so I
like that aspect of his game yeah I
worry about the run fits for him he got
moved all over the field by big physical
offensive linemen so I think he is gonna
be a piece that comes in and he fills a
very specific role on third down I just
don't think he can be on the field for
first and second down yeah and we'll see
developmental guy round five your New
York Jets are on deck on the clock any
predictions of Kelvin Harmon I don't
think they're the team to do it but I
mean like we see Matt's best available
again - I'd like to see you know where
we can what kind of direction we can go
here with the New York Jets they still
have a lot of needs left got this
interesting David long fits their system
trade Darren Lee draft that's it that
David long yeah and he's a lot I mean
he's a tough guy David long so
eventually if you traded Darren Lee
David long would make sense if they want
to back up for Robbie Anderson with
speed Emanuel Hall is there I think they
feel so they brought in a lot of running
backs considering they you know they
signed ty Montgomery that obviously gave
levy on bail a lot of money so can't
completely rule out running back because
of their interest in the pre-draft
process here but I mean you know I buy
it at my way of the Kelvin Harmon Mello
any thoughts for those you
your jets escorted Jets jacket today
yeah rocket for Conner every once in a
while he likes it when I do I would like
to see a running back fit there you got
a guy like treyvion Williams who can
catch the ball out of the backfield you
know that that's what lay me on Belle
does he also misses some games too I
know he has a nice new contract but you
need depth behind him I wouldn't mind
seeing one of those rum running backs
come off the board yeah I know we talked
before about depth that wide receiver at
Manuel Hall from Missouri is still
available if they wanted to go with the
speed guy instead of you know someone
like Kelvin Harmon like you said it
seems like they've tried that so they're
actually gonna linebacker but it is not
who we thought it's not David long
junior it is an athlete a tester from
Minnesota Blake Cashman is the pick this
is all day about traits here
it really is you talk about speed and
explosiveness and undersized kind of
linebacker but he's similar into that
mold is David long as somebody that will
probably play around maybe 230 pounds at
best it looks at time so Cashman had a
phenomenal combine and I think this is
one of those chess pieces for Greg
Williams worth hey he could take away
the flats for me he can help out in
coverage but you see it right here yes
six he doesn't know to do this he's
hitting biceps every single Friday good
work for 546 95 three cone that change
of direction so the thing about play
Cashman is he breathes reads football
and Greg Williams is pounding the table
for those guys and I know you love
anyone that works out with a headband on
so you got a like oh yeah yeah I might
have had a say in this one yeah you like
this one so I like Blake Cashman again
athlete at four five speed playing
middle linebacker
read and react here I would like to see
a little more activity but thought he
sniffed out this screen well he comes
that he'll pull the chain a little bit
and although he's a pretty good hitter
in the open this is the guy that our
friend Jared Brown said that we needed
to be higher on you watch this tape and
I like what are you seeing out of him
he's a very physical guy who can come in
and be a good locker room he's not gonna
cause any problems he wasn't a starter
at Minnesota until a senior year and
that concerns me but you know what maybe
he just turned it on maybe things really
clicked with him in a scheme and in a
fit and we saw that production finally
so I like it in the fifth round yeah 157
if you can get an athlete at linebacker
where you're probably gonna lose Darren
Lee and we might see more for linebacker
sets from them so CJ Mosley gets a
monster
on track but they actually need some
depth there I like Avery Williamson but
depth is always good I was gonna say
this pic to me signals the end of the
Darren Lee era in New York you would
think they have some kind of deal on the
table as we get to the end of the fifth
round here maybe they can only fetch a
sixth from very interesting so serious
to see if the trickle effect of that is
a Darren Lee trade guys the Dallas
Cowboys are on the clock this pic
started with Pittsburgh then it went to
Oakland then I went to Buffalo then it
went to oh container now it's back in
Dallas this pic has been everywhere and
hopefully we'll see the Cowboys actually
use it the fact that Oakland had it
twice and moved on from is interesting
we don't want this bit right yeah it's
been around this pic it's been around
the block it's seen some things and I do
want to get to one of our hashtag be our
draft questions because our buddy Dan
Kiefer sent one in and he says Melo can
we get a 2020 Big Bird teaser Dan keeper
I don't know what the hell that is manic
bird but there will be a big board
teaser later today if you're interested
in 2020 already I'll work on a big bird
teaser I don't know what that is man but
if the people wanted I'll do it it's
more of a Cookie Monster guy myself
not so much Big Bird I mean you're
afraid big teaser yeah
I saw someone out also asking Connor and
I to grade your debut we'll do that
that's the end of it I still have some
questions left yeah I know we're point
nine it's a number grid yeah dad to give
me a book cuz usually it's like Miller
we need 11 rate and I'm like it's at
10:00 it's a really good pick so the
Cowboys pick will be coming and very
shortly Cowboys have had again they they
watched him re Cooper highlights in the
first round and then I thought they did
a good job of just addressing needs
they've just like going down the box
addressing needs to Dallas Cowboys ever
Tristan Hill we talked about the Rod
Marinelli fit Connor McGovern cook
versatile offensive lineman a huge need
for them Tony Pollard a chess piece a
Swiss Army knife in the backfield with
Zeke Elliot that's gonna be a fun combo
watching those two together with dak
Prescott a quarterback yeah and he might
be their new kick returner there so
interesting to keep an eye on that and
also this next pick will see if they
have to sign this I'm gonna show up for
practice and wait and lift a contract
that exists apparently so do they name
that after David Irving that's what I
want to know how do I get one of those
in my contract a work ethic
I say are you asking for I want a work
ethic like bonus like a kicker you know
like what later we're doing here wait
you know you see guys all the time like
they got money if they I don't want that
one funny that might be that all that
way around they might be I all right
Matt you're gonna need to cut ten pounds
right I'm do that sure they would love
me to do that but I didn't mean more
like if my articles come in on time you
know like God Miller working today Matt
wants more money for doing these jobs a
clear Tonio brown we're waiting on that
pic as a reminder guys send your
questions hashtag BR draft and one more
reminder when we get off the clock after
round five you could check your B app BR
app a couple hours later me and Matt are
gonna be grading every single draft so
probably nice to your team maybe we
won't be a whole sipara I'm an easy
grader yeah yeah it's gonna happen and
then Monday morning we will have a stick
to football podcast for you guys to
check out and then Wednesday morning
Friday morning will be we'll be back on
schedule after this so as the pic slow
down a little bit the Cowboys got this
one from the Dolphins part of that
Robert Quinn trade so they added a pass
rusher with this pick but I was part of
the flip of getting Robert Quinn so
they've they've filled really a lot of
needs the Cowboys have we got the
Patriots on the clock after this fall by
the Ravens and Texans as we start to get
to the middle part of round five so
still good talent on the board like you
said Connor we looked at the big board
guys available I love it when the
production leads me there and we
actually have the Pitt guys they went
corner we talked about big corners to up
there on the board there's one of the
biggest Michael Jackson senior he's a
thriller six foot one 210 pounds from
the Hurricanes he rocks that turnover
chain a decent amount for the you and
yeah I mean gotta love the ability here
we're gonna grade this pick because all
the cowboys and they apparently have a
fan or two out there in the country but
I need at corner they needed to get some
depth here guys and they get one I might
be a hard grader on this one I don't
know just now that I've been called out
I might you know what b-plus hard grade
yeah watch this yeah so Tristan Hill
Connor McGovern Tony Pollard and now
Michael Jackson so not a lot of huge
names but let's get into this one the
Dallas Cowboys needed depth
corner they need its size a corner they
got both with michael jackson senior
from the you Miami Hurricanes Connor I
know you saw this student person this
year he s size he has ball skills balls
a little bit in the draft here after a
really good protest yeah he does so I'm
against Florida State Hill he likes to
mix it up big physical corner I think he
fits with Dallas wants you see it right
there the size and the speed and the
ability to jump and fight for the
football so I like Michael Jackson and I
really really like him in this spot for
Dallas like I said an ideal scheme fit
with some ball skills it's not afraid to
mix it up with the line of scrimmage and
a - throughout for me here with this
pick I love this big - I'm gonna give it
a b-plus I am a little bit harder of a
grader I think this guy comes in he is a
smooth criminal
you watch him moonwalk with those
receivers he can flip his hips if he can
just face the man in the mirror I think
we got a real thriller here all right
Wow be my history me that was amazing
give that an a I do it Michael Jackson I
like Chris Boyd better so looking at the
corner so we're all on the board I like
what they get here sighs at corner is a
little bit rare for them after they go
with some smaller guys but the Cowboys
get someone the wheel believe is gonna
make a big impact at the star that was
well done that was really good that was
like we can grade your performance now
now people are like now we see why he's
on the podcast
he knows Michael Jackson songs yeah I
knew you were gonna get man in the
mirror in there oh that's the best one
that's right guys the Patriots have
traded up in this draft with the Vikings
and they draft the player who at one
time was a top high school recruit moved
around at Maryland Byron Cowart
defensive end maybe a defensive tackle
can play a little bit all over the line
but he's an athlete you think about they
lose Trey flowers we've seen them like
add guys like Michael Bennett in the
past I think this is kind of a similar
type of player yeah I'm with you all the
way there it's you know it's good to see
some of these Maryland defenders get
some love we saw at night number one
with savage coward it's an interesting
player a good year for him I think he's
strong against the run he has some size
up front it did take a little while like
you said Matt big-time recruit teams are
always gonna take chances on those guys
so not a high ceiling player in my eyes
anymore but if you're looking for value
with the higher floor here I like to
pick yeah it is round 5 is this pig hits
look like geniuses and it definitely
could he's got the traits the athletic
ability to move around with that
defensive line this is their type this
is what the Cowboys want they go get it
and round five it's a great pick for
them Mel are you still giving it a B+ or
are you just keeping that grade up there
maybe let's do you just hit that Michael
Jackson video so strong you're just
keeping it up there so the Patriots they
continue to have a good draft today and
I like here that they roll in dice a
little bit on someone like we were Sant
Connor who developed late at Maryland
they did Wow didn't always make the
biggest play for them but there's still
some size definitely sizes 6/3 300
pounds has some athleticism and fills a
need the Baltimore Ravens around the
clock they might go another pass rusher
I thought they were gonna run the triple
option next year nope that at Hollywood
Brown that at Miles Boykin after we saw
them go tightened heavy last year so
they've really invested in trying to
help Lamar Jackson
with some pass catchers I still think
defense is a need for this team though
yeah and they there it is right there
they get defensive help from a guy that
I really like Dale and Mack out of Texas
A&M had a great senior season was
another guy Kyler Murray's best friend
they both agreed to go to Texas A&M
together one of them stayed there and
turned into a very big just yeah pillar
they have Brandon Williams already this
is another guy that can come in and play
a very similar role to that yeah while
adding depth all along the interior
defensive line and we talked about Cour
being a former five-star that things
took a little while to develop daelin
Mack is the same exact story here and
you see it with the size of 336 a little
stout I think he has he developed that
power and leverage on the inside to win
so you're looking for somebody that
could play shade knows there's a really
good process for Dale and Matt what I
loved about him he goes to the shrine
game and he dominates and then they call
him up to the senior ball I all right
big boy let's see if you can do it here
but he dominated again and then he had a
good combine like you said he owned the
process it clicked a little bit late for
him I want to give credit to Jimbo
Fisher staff because they lit whatever
fire needed to be lit under him and he
became like an old SEC performer don't
work for Alabama he probably would have
been an all-sec performer the production
is there he like Melo said he can play
as your knows he can play as a shade one
he can move all over that D line and
give them some versatility as they moved
between a three and four man front
that's still a true hybrid defense in
Baltimore and how many times did we see
Tamura take a defensive lineman that
needs a little more refinement on day
three and they find a way to make them a
five six seven eight year starter that
was Brandon Williams I mean the third
round but getting someone late who
needed coached up a little bit and then
they then made him into a Pro Bowl
player Mays first per Bowl this past
year the Houston Texans are on the clock
that pick is coming in followed by the
Vikings Eagles and then the Colts so
some playoff teams here about to make
some picks
we've been Houston has been all over
that offensive line yeah they have added
some in the secondary haven't seen a lot
of front seven from them so that might
be a direction that they try to add some
depth here as we get into round five
maybe this is where Gerald Willis
finally comes off the board where you do
take a chance on a talent like that a
top talent like that I say it bugs is
still out there we talked about his fall
earlier so the defensive line it's
starting to thin out real quickly here
jenavian clowny also franchise tag
player has not signed that there's been
some talk that he might be traded we
didn't see that happen it could still
happen after the draft but if there's an
edge rusher out there we talked about
Joe Jackson Charles and many who they're
still players out there that could at
least attempt to get after the
quarterback that might be able to help
soften that blow if they were to lose
him and I think actually this would be a
good landing spot for a mini Hewitt I
think he can come in and play similar to
what JJ Watt does not to that level
obviously but he can be that big guy on
the end he's not gonna get you a true
three-four edge rusher but I think he
can still kick inside add some pass rush
from the interior if they went this
direction it would be a very good fit
for him yeah it would be I think like
you said before he can play that v Tech
they ain't a four-man front he can
bounce outside and play the six Jagger
Walker a good athlete someone we had on
the stick football podcast a fun
interview but hurt in the process I
believe was a hernia
the side he missed I'm late in this
process of teams might be worried about
how quickly he can get back on the field
we've seen that before you're a third or
fourth round player you get an injury a
lot of times you become a sixth or
seventh round pick
yeah and Porter Gustin was somebody I
really likes but there's some some
rumors of maybe a failed drug test for
peds so I mean you look at him he's
pretty jacked yeah they said was
adderall okay good so he had a waiver
but you know how that goes out a roll do
you get popped for it in the end of thon
you don't have the waiver
yeah you get a suspension it's probably
to be a Seahawk by the end of the day
yeah probably
Carol when you look at when he was on
the field which was rarely he was very
impressive layer so I like the value
injuries were a big part of the problem
he was a top recruit as well back in
then we looked at both of those guys
last year as people we would highlight
come in and Smith and Porter Gustin just
didn't live up to that production and
that's why a lot of times people ask us
do you take into account high school
rankings absolutely not because it's a
whole new ballgame once you get to USC
you've got to have that production there
it's not just oh you were five star we
talked about Dale and Mack five star guy
it doesn't matter until you get on the
field for your Division one team guys
and Charles and many who did go here to
the Houston Texans pick 23 in the fifth
round this is one 61 overall so Melo you
called it a many Hugh a good fit for
what the Texans want to do up front
we're gonna grade this pick
congratulation that was a good call look
at you boys I'm so proud of you today
just now he looks left and right and
some about that seat Connor it gives you
some any hue we'll have to move far from
Austin to Houston it's about a four-hour
drive stop at Bucky's and fill up with
some snacks on the way the Houston
Texans add a big defensive end stop me
if you've heard this one before guys he
was also very productive in the big 12
the defensive lineman of the year in the
conference he can get after the
quarterback he's six foot five thirty
five inch arms and many who has some
untapped potential we didn't always see
him turn it on at Texas though yeah the
motor was hot and cold let's be real
there but you see the length obviously
and that's what you love about this guy
and I think there was some production
there are times like you said Matt when
the game was on the line in the fourth
quarter you saw him that turn on you see
him ripping off the offensive line there
I really like his ability on the ends
and I think Melo said earlier maybe he
can gain some weight and become more
stout run defender and that's the role
frame at the next level so at this point
in the trap this is Abbey for me I don't
think oh man and you should be asked to
come in and be this stud pass rusher he
needs some development but this is good
value yeah and I'm actually I'm gonna go
a here because I do love the fit and
what he can do I you talked about him
being maybe a tweener he's not a true
edge rusher he doesn't have to be with
Houston if you want him to gain a little
bit of weight play with JJ Watt and go
up to the cabin do whatever you
- do I like the fit here because I think
that defense can motivate him I think
he's another guy that came in maybe a
little bit entitled with that charlie
strong defense of the oh we already made
it well no you have it and so maybe now
we're seeing that work ethic develop
with a mini heal and that can carry on
in Houston Texas guy so he gets to stay
home yeah I'm gonna go to be plus guys
well you've been on trade Sears 36-inch
arms that size had a great Senior Bowl
pretty good combine as well so hopefully
we could see guys like Romeo Crennel
unlocked the potential trouble so many
Houston Texans get a really good value
here at the end of round five good fit
for him and then our guy we talked about
two players they get drafted Cameron
Smith goes off the board to the
Minnesota Vikings pick 24 in round five
someone who lost about 20 pounds this
year try to get leaner he was playing at
255 at one point he gets down to 238 we
see he'd better range from him he was
banged up nicked up a lot at USC but
he'll come down the hill and pop so I
liked this fit man they've never really
had like that go-to inside linebacker
with the Vikings events good players
they're never a great player I'm excited
to see where he fits into this team
special teams you see playing covering a
little bit yeah big night I think the
shedding the weight was huge for him
because you look at his role at the next
level can he be that Nickel linebacker
that can help you in coverage erase the
flats hopefully run with tight ends a
little bit but like you said Matt he is
not afraid to come down hill and make a
tackle so cam Smith this is great value
for him I think teams wanted to see him
play at that lighter weight they want to
see him stay healthy this is where you
take an off ball linebacker like him
yeah I really like it too he's a guy
that can come be physical kind of play
in the trash and you see that seal on
his jersey again that's a very big thing
to a lot of coaches yeah it's the New
England Patriots we've talked about what
a great draft they have had well they
just drafted a punter
Jake Bailey out of Stanford a little bit
of a surprise or around five but when
the paper I mean if the Patriots are
gonna do it I guess you know it's hard
to complain when it's Bill Belichick
they trade it up to take a punter never
mind that's dumb Thank You Reed thank
you I don't care if bill wash himself
called you from heaven and told Bill
Belichick to do this and then he signed
off on it with the ghost of Tom Landry
beside him
don't trade up to draft a punter there's
a lot going on with what you just said
but I agree with you Oh Billy must be on
a bathroom break because I just don't
know why you trade up to take a punter I
mean you're giving up another pick for
this just hang out wait go eat an Eskimo
Pie just hang on
wait for your punter you don't have to
trade up for him it's I don't Alan what
that was actually a pretty decent putter
as far as my evaluation of the punting
position goes so a little bit of a
surprise they do love special teams up
there we're in the fifth round still the
throw aways that are later than Tom
Brady I'm gonna be the one who says that
I mean no it's facts drafted before Matt
Bowen like good players who still get
drafted after this point I think Richard
Sherman was drafted after this and you
guys gonna trade up for a punter you'll
win another Super Bowl congrats well the
Colts are on the clock I think Chris
Ballard will pick you know make a real
pain corner and yeah there we go
so they take a wide receiver they're a
small school my goodness yes Chris
Bergeron Oliver AJ speed from Tarleton
State yeah not my top one I'm nothing
yeah he did not make our rankings but I
will tell you he sounds fast that's what
I have he's got the name for it and I
think he was actually listed there out
we saw wide receiver I actually had him
noted as a linebacker so I'm the little
confused as we're seeing different
things come in no way yeah so he okay
this is why you guys might have been
confused because that we solved we have
the other broadcast they listed a
receiver he's not he's a linebacker
right but he was twice arrested he was
arrested on two felony counts back in
September of 2018 for organized criminal
activity he's a mob boss so he's mobbed
up a little bit somebody called in a
favor and got this guy drafted but he
was he had done a lot of team visits so
yeah recheck your boards he might be in
there but a linebacker from tarlatan
state a very good athlete he was hurt in
2017 then the arrest happens but we've
said before Chris Ballard is okay he'll
go visit these guys this is what I did
with Marcus Peters raised in Kansas City
everyone said Marcus was undrafted he
had gotten kicked off the Washington
team Ballard goes out there spins a
weekend with him was like no I'm good
with this kid I'm okay with it
so EJ Speedline
Packer from tarlatan State I don't know
where tarlatan state is but I think it's
actually in Texas so now they're
Ballard's from Ballard is from Texas
these guys probably went to the same
high school
he is probably how he knows who he is
yeah I'll tell you what is a fun thing
to do is you pull up your big board from
NFL Draft 400 and you do a control find
for the word speed no any search for
tarlatan yeah
organized crime though that's one you
don't hear very often no I've seen a lot
of arrest records on my nine years kind
of like adderall okay heard of that
before
marijuana yep organized crime not
something I've ever seen in a scouting
report no six foot four 230 pound
linebacker out of Fort Worth Texas
though yeah heat meant made a ton of
place the Dallas Cowboys are on the
clock though guys let's get back to a
college you've heard of Joe Jackson
Michael's dad goes to the Dallas Cowboys
at defensive end out of the you so to
Jackson's from Miami get drafted in this
round they needed a defensive end guys
we're gonna grade this pick because it
is the Cowboys yeah and yeah so tarlatan
state is thank you to Tom Phillip I love
this guy they spent some time at Miami's
the Cowboys yeah cowboy spent a little
time I mean I worked for them in the
past
so they took Michael Jackson they took
Joe Jackson they got the Jackson 5 on
that defense so the Dallas Cowboys are
going back to their roots with the you
they got some guys there the past Jimmie
Johnson Michael Irvin they worked out
the Robo Joe Jackson works out in the
fifth round a big defensive in at 275
pounds yeah this is a power player this
is a big defensive end with strong hands
I think he's very very strong off the
snap so once again when you saw him down
against Florida State he dominated that
football game and you see it right here
yeah he might not be the best athlete in
terms of change of direction and even
long speed but he's got the arm lengthen
the sides to hold his own on the edge
out there and I really like the value
here they're going back down to that
Miami defense the turnover chain here
for the Cowboys and a minus for me at
this pick yeah and I'm right there with
you Connor I think we're just some
padico over here I'm gonna give it up B
I like the fit too with Dallas you get a
big guy that can play on the end of your
defensive line with good production out
of the ACC
you go back to Miami very good pick very
good value if you're a Cowboys fan yeah
two picks out of Miami in this round I
like both of them I'm gonna give this
one a B+ as well I think Jackson in that
rotation you got to worry about Randy
Gregory you just sign tank warrants but
you do have some depth concerns there
because of some of the guys that they've
missed on in the past take taco Charlton
has done nothing Joe Jackson's built
very similarly to him I'm excited for
this pig the Dallas Cowboys get another
Miami hurricane in round five all right
guys the Chargers are on the clock
followed by the Eagles then the Titans
Rams and browns so yeah tarlatan stayed
up and threw me so a little surprise
there so we're almost to the end of
round five guys thank you so much for
hanging out with us today again a
reminder Connor and I will be in your be
our App grading every team's pick so go
download that if you haven't already
bleacher report.com slash mobile or just
go to your App Store download it it's
free it's amazing you can watch this
coverage here follow all our work
throughout the draft season subscribe to
the stick to football podcast there so
the Chargers pick 28 they're about to
make that as we get down 166 overall out
of 254 in this draft
so Chargers guys thoughts on the draft
so far still some quarterbacks available
here is the first thought that I had
yeah maybe they want to take a flyer
here I don't think this is something
that would upset papa Phillip Rivers too
much you can get a guy in the 5th round
and Phil will be okay with yeah I think
that's the question here are they gonna
allow any kind of quarterback in that
room so I think Tyree Jackson it's a
little bit of surprising he's still on
the board obviously Brett ripping could
go Matt's favorite quarterback in the
draft Gardner Minshew is still hanging
around right where those doors know his
stash with Phil's bolo tie elite
quarterback room it's definitely a back
room in the NFL so and tie rods got
Thomas way high res guys yeah tie rod is
all swagged out yeah the Chargers I am
curious to see what they do here I think
they could still get impact players they
needed some help in that front seven my
god David long is still sitting there so
I've lost Tyrell Williams a free agency
yeah they've had some struggles with
with health there at the receiver
position they are gonna go quarterback
boys and one of our favorite players
he's been on the stick to football
podcast Easton stick North Dakota State
the player who took
over for Carson Wentz when he got hurt
we're gonna grade this pick guys because
we are big fans of mr. stick to the
bison is he gonna play slot receiver
slot receiver his three-cone was like
legend his three-cone was legendary yeah
so Russia but here's a good quarterback
in and finally they draft someone to
develop behind Philip Rivers so it's
gonna be a lot of fun to see what he
does there
the Los Angeles chargers we've said they
need another quarterback they get
another quarterback one of the most
productive one of the winningest in this
draft Easton stick from North Dakota
State you might remember when Carson
Wentz got hurt as a senior this is a
dude that came in and kept the Train
running as they made a national
championship run Easton stick he's
accurate he's a good athlete not a ton
of arm strength and maybe suffered
against the level of competition yeah I
love the athleticism with Eastern six
game he can roll out extend plays I
think the arm strength is questionable
but a very accurate player a playmaker
he's won a lot of games there so I think
the value here is fine there are a
couple better quarterbacks on the board
when you look at Tyree Jackson Brett
ripping it maybe even Gardner Minshew
Zinn this range so it's a b-minus for me
they got a you know a crowded
quarterback room over there but Easton
stick it's good to see him get drafted
in a landing spot where he's gonna sit
for a while I'm a little bit of a hard
grader here but I'm going with an egg
because I like the fact that they're
getting a quarterback finally in a guy
that's very athletic develop him you
might have three to four years of Philip
Rivers left come develop Easton stick he
took over for Carson Wentz they didn't
miss a beat very athletic guy even
though he came on the podcast and said
he wasn't it runs a four six great
athlete not a strong arm Phillip Rivers
didn't have a strong arm either though I
really like this pick I'm giving in an a
I'm actually give it a b-minus I agree
there were some better quarterbacks on
the board I liked Tyree Jackson I like
Clayton Clayton Thorson loved Gardner
Minshew but Easton stick and there's
something to this guy's game that
wouldn't be surprised if this becomes a
Kirk Cousins type quarterback for the
Los Angeles chargers as we see them need
at quarterback down the road Easton
stick all right and back-to-back
quarterbacks guys we're gonna grade this
one too because we want to grade all the
quarterbacks to get picked the Eagles
couldn't get the guy that backed up
Carson went so they take Clayton Thorson
so these quarterbacks are just I'm
making a lot of hand motions because
they're all over the place so handsy
today oh yeah they're just feel like a
baseball season I'm ready to call steals
and bunts all right let's get right into
this one guys get your grater ready good
to go didn't have to move it the
Philadelphia Eagles have been worried
about the health of Carson Wentz they
might have an answer of the backup
position Nick Foles goes to Jacksonville
in comes Clayton Thorson 53 starts in
college very very smart coming out of
Northwestern yeah this is the poorest
man's Carson Wentz version he's got
mobility he's got size he's been banged
up in college but you see right there 6
for 222 he can move well I do like the
arm strength here so I like that the
Eagles add someone to this quarterback
room that can grow and a lot of
potential here a lot of upside with this
pick
it's a b-minus for me I did like Tyree
Jackson still sitting on the board there
along with Brett ripping but Clayton
Thorson has a lot of potential yeah and
I'm gonna go surprise pic here I'm
giving it an F because if you want to
backup for Carson Wentz
it's got to be Easton stick you move up
to take Easton stick I wanted to see it
I didn't even know as a possibility so
I'm giving it an F even though I like
Clayton Thorson I think he can come in
and really develop behind wins and throw
in when he does get hurt because we are
going to see that it's an F because I
wanted it to be Easton stick Melo has
biases I'm giving it a beat I like the
development potential I talked to Scouts
to share in the road they said Clayton
Thorson had the worst situation around
him of any quarterback from the 2019
draft class at Northwestern let's see
what he can do behind a very good
offensive line in Philly we know Carson
Wentz is gonna miss time this guy behind
Nate said build could be that answer
when Wentz can't go you're a mean grader
I like the player it's just a joke it's
funny I do like the player though it's
just I wanted to see a B Eastern steak
because that would be hilarious
they need a backup quarterback you go
get the guy that was his backup already
forsen does a good player though he has
some arm strength he had some injury
concerns he didn't have anything around
him so in the fifth round I am very
surprised to see both these quarterbacks
go off the dirt off the board with Tyree
Jackson there I really thought this guy
was gonna go much much higher guys the
second highest rated player on my board
just came off
that board deandre walker from georgia
pass rusher goes to the tennessee titans
we had called this out as a need for
them they wanted to get guys upset
Harold Landry now they add another one
in January Walker again it good
interview when we had him on we've
talked to him pretty good athlete he
couldn't test because the hernia issue
but we've seen them go edge rusher
earlier in this draft they got Jeffrey
Simmons of course then they went down
sir Walker here excuse me so that's the
first true edge they want to get some
more speed on this deeper I was gonna
say this feels like a backup for Harold
Landry here they get away from taking
one of the big edges that Mike Vrabel
likes now and Harold Landry who's had an
injury history on his own maybe Walker's
the answer has some depth behind him
yeah and I like it too I think if there
weren't that injury concerns that he
might not be there in round five this
guy came on strong in the college
football playoff seven and a half sacks
there even though he fought through some
injuries couldn't play in the Texas game
I like his game and I like his fit with
the Titans so that's a great pick for
Tennessee and for able to go get another
guy they can get after the quarterback
credible value at this point I don't
think the entree Walker deserved this
slide this far especially we had a
handful of punters a handful handful
yeah I like down dray Walker I think
there's good upside here and that the
fact that you get magneto Mike Vrabel
who knows a little bit about pass
rushers we got a question from Matt GN a
Tino
nailed it Kelvin Harmon for the Giants
coming up question mark I mean it would
be a good pick I'll say that but I can't
keep saying Kelvin Harmon for every team
because clearly no team wants him right
now
so how surprised are you and I want to
just mention this because I want to talk
about how good he is as a player not to
throw shots yeah he was your top
receiver for a good part of the season
yeah we didn't finish that way for a
reason he was my third receiver but when
it comes down to it I mean I don't know
why he's there maybe speed if that's
your reason we see good wide receivers
fall all the time I mean look at Michael
Thomas a couple years ago there's
another example so yeah I guess it's
speed he's a physical player I thought
he was a nuance route runner he's great
at the catch point he's good after the
catch I can't wait for him to get
drafted Koosman will show the highlights
like I don't know what we're missing
yeah something we talked about he's
tough a lot is the NFL likes these guys
more than we do I think the
fell light Ryan Finley a lot more than
we did yes so when they watch that North
Carolina State tape they say oh my gosh
look at this throw Ryan Finley made
whereas Connor you probably watched it
you say look at the body adjustment at
Kelvin Harmon just exactly that's an
incredible catch a terrible throw so I
think there's the difference and it
doesn't mean that you're wrong I'm not
not saying that I was a fever and
Antonio Brown not a fan of Ryan Finley
so to see the slide here is very
surprising but I think that's the
difference in how you view that tape for
sure and I think when you look at
Harmons game he's the perfect number to
wide receiver for an NFL offense he's
somebody that will he always be the best
at separating no but if you throw him
the football he's a reliable player and
once again on screens he's fantastic
slants drag routes so I mean he's an
ideal number to target in the league
right now and this was a draft that was
lacking true number one threats but I
don't understand this kind of fall
gentlemen we got five picks left and
around five then we will be bouncing out
of here to grade every team's draft but
I have good news for you
don't leave the stream when we get down
to the final picks do not leave the
stream because we are going to preview
for you the 2020 NFL Draft Melo has a
big board I have a big board we're gonna
run through some of the names that
you'll want to know for next year so if
you want to beat your friends to the
punch when everybody's talking about the
draft Monday if you want to be the guy
that's like yeah but let me tell you
about next year next year's a good draft
so stick around hang out with us here
we're not going anywhere right when
around five ins the Rams are on the
clock then we have the Browns Giants
Falcons Redskins so teams that we've
liked everyone's draft here and the Rams
have taken an offensive tackle this is a
future need for them David Edwards comes
up the board from Wisconsin yeah and
somebody with a ton of playing
experience for one of the best rushing
attacks in the country so I think when
you look at it here this is somebody
that the Rams would want he can actually
be a it's weird when you get an
offensive lineman in the fifth round
that's kind of Pro ready he's just a
limited player that's the difference
yeah I thought Letta Kalihi was pretty
poor but fir you come out of Wisconsin
you're usually pretty battle-tested
watch them here number 79 and right
tackle he could anchor take out an
anchor there being he is big six-foot
six 308 pounds arm link was a little
weird he kind of a weird body 33 and 3/8
inch arms you don't expect that from
someone his size but this is a neat as
they get older on the offensive line
where he
could be a future player for them yeah I
do wonder if he has a future at tackle I
think you can talk about the short arms
and the weird body and I mean they're
not showing the vertical here you can
barely jump off the ground at 25 and it
is but once again he's a power player
maybe my thought with this pick is
actually in goal line maybe the Rams are
looking for a jumbo they get a sixth
offensive lineman this would be the type
of guy that you bring in those situation
that's why I wanted to highlight too I
think this is a guard tackle type fit
for this team you need depth and he can
provide it at both those spots you need
a run blocker he can come in and pave a
way for a team to run behind and you
want to keep Todd Gurley healthy go get
him a big Wisconsin lineman it helped do
that yeah in Wisconsin I will say this
about offensive lineman we talked oh
it's round five there are a lot of
starting offensive linemen in the NFL
that came from round five so I would not
discount someone being around five pick
and thinking that oh they're only going
to be a backup for a long time look at
the Patriots offensive line it's a lot
of dudes who were not priority picks
outside of Isaiah when it was a first
rounder the Browns are on the clock my
pick to win the AFC North this year and
I said that before I think they had a
toe dealt this is a very good team they
add Olivier Vernon obviously Odell comes
in to add cream hunt they have Baker
Mayfield the quarterback it's a very
very good team of the draft so far
impact players from big schools greedy
Williams children Redwine trying to fix
that secondary patch some holes co taki
taki they lose Jamie Collins this might
be your answer there and then Mack
Wilson at linebacker you like that
attack attack attack he's hockey
oh yeah this is I'm gonna be transparent
this is not my favorite trap Brede
Williams is a slam dunk at 46 after that
whatever I mean I thought talking talk
he was to reach it 80 there but I like
that they address it is secondary a
little bit getting red wine and I think
this is a team that's expected to win
their division at this point well this
guy might help because no one that
they've drafted will score more points
than kicker Austin cyber from Oklahoma
round 5 is the run on specialist what is
the long snapper from Indiana coming on
before that's what I want to know right
now I won't be long man chubby kicker
love it when that happens
never mind yeah 5 9 to 14 so yeah man he
was accurate I'll say this
and make some big place almost 500
points scored in college so that is a
big 12 record I think I might actually
be the most all-time at Oklahoma so
really productive they also scored a lot
of points there so it's not give him all
the credit for that but a kicker to the
Browns this might be like Baker Mayfield
drinking buddy or something like Alice
yeah as you bring them up yeah there's
Siamese up here I needed me clear
anytime definitely some Baker influence
with this pick all the way yeah and the
Giants are now on the clock you're very
curious to they have rebounded nicely
since its we have the picker actually
they've gone wide receiver Gary Slayton
from Auburn I like that picks a lot
there is Slayton getting some size a
wide receivers a small nudes so now you
have somebody that maybe stretch the
field give you a little bit of an
over-the-top yeah I mean Darius Slayton
you want to talk about a vertical tar
game we talked about how Jared Stidham
basically had to run for his life this
year when the ball was snapped that
didn't help Darius Slayton who wins over
the top so that's the problem here we
talked about it affecting Stidham it
also affected Slayton he would have been
drafted a lot earlier if he had better
production it just simply was we're
gonna grade this pick guys for three
nine speed so he fully could fly the New
York Giants needed a receiver after
trading Odell Beckham well now they have
some speed at least with Darius Slayton
from Auburn dude's got four three nine
speed fellas a seven second three cone
he's got speed to burn he's gonna
stretch the field for those New York
Giants yeah this is someone that will
take the top off of the defense and as
we talked about earlier in the Auburn
offense maybe the opportunities weren't
always there but you see the athleticism
there it's phenomenal and he was open a
lot on tape but the Auburn offensive
line simply could not block long enough
to give him time to connect with the
quarterback but here you see him his
ability to turn up the field I really
like this pick for the Giants they do
need a vertical target for that offense
and you're seeing a lot of short throws
here but he can win over the safeties
this is an a for me for those New York
Giants rebounding nicely on day three
yeah and I'm gonna go with a B+ for this
one I think he might be a one-trick pony
at receiver but you can bet on that one
trick because he can hit the deep route
I don't think the Giants have a
quarterback that can out throw Darius
Slayton right now a very elite speed in
four threes good pick here I'm gonna go
b-plus I'm gonna write between you guys
how about that a
- for me I like that they've added speed
and a little bit of sizes 6 foot 1 190
now you've got guys like sterling
shepherd you've got Golden Tate you've
got some smaller receivers now you have
someone who can at least get some
safeties out of the box that's gonna
help say quantum Berkeley we like this
pick for the Giants at the end of round
5 Darius Leighton from Auburn 2 picks
left guys and around five-30 fours the
Atlanta Falcons 35 will be the
Washington Redskins and the pick is
actually in for Atlanta their last pick
was quadri Allison the running back from
Pitt a big bruiser so they've kind of
gone that's been the theme here for yeah
it's like tough guys Ritz Lindstrom
Kayla McGarry all assent from Pitt so
yeah a lot of big physical players for
Atlanta in this draft class kendall
Sheffield not that at all but speed out
on the edge quite the opposite of that I
think we can Bank on the fact they're
not taking an offensive lineman here I'd
be a surprise yeah be a little bit of a
surprise you know I think that they
actually could look at defensive line
Gerald Willis this could be the hot spot
for him I think you talk about somebody
that can win as a pastor under Dan Quinn
love John Kaminsky came in there I don't
know if they would would view those guys
as similar to this one I'm back with him
David long junior fits the mold that the
Falcons like at linebacker there was
some talk initially that they would try
to trade up but guys they've actually
gotten corner here Jordan Miller from
Washington a good player overshadowed by
Byron Murphy who was banged up this past
year but four four nine speed two-year
starter at corner he has good size it at
six feet tall so they go with Sheffield
and now Miller which maybe tells us what
the the truth might be about Desmond
true fonts future someone who's been
there for a long time
Miller was impressive he was very sticky
and coverage went on the field some of
those receivers in the pac-12 are very
talented when you talk about Nikhil
Harry Dylan Mitchell type so I liked
what I saw from Miller he was underrated
in that secondary that had start Allen
tin Taylor rap and Byron Murphy no ankle
injury just shut him down yeah you know
I like it too I mean this is a guy who
played for four years in Washington I
think comes in and immediately as a
special teams contributor at the very
minimum in or at the back end around
five like that's what you need out of
these guys yeah and they they have
checked needs like they've really
thought okay we offensive line fixed all
we need depth of the secondary fixed so
I think they've they've set themselves
up in
checked a lot of boxes the Redskins are
on the clock 35 overall in this round
I'd be the last pick around five but
remember hang around we're gonna preview
a little bit of twenty20 before Connor
and I grade every team's draft so the
stream will end when we're double 2020
open your app those videos are gonna be
populating quickly let go said he
subscribes to all 32 teams in the app I
don't I might because that's a really
good idea I mean you're not gonna miss
any breaking news yeah if you go with
all 32 teams it's really it's a pretty
good idea I think I'm gonna do it when
we're done here today yeah so one more
pick then we're actually we're gonna
grade mellow - don't forget then we're
gonna talk about some twenty20 big
boards you know I see maybe a tough
grader buddy boy yeah whatever I'm the
biggest guy on this death who A's are
about to come up yeah there's gonna be
some payback for you big mom and dad's
favorite right here it's gonna happen at
the end of the strap so Redskins here
Connor any any players you'd like to see
come off the board other than Calvin
Harmon I think I would like to see David
long jr. honestly here I think they've
done a brilliant job of getting some big
bodies in that front seven on the
defensive line get a guy that can run
around and make plays behind them yeah
and they we've seen them you know go
after big school guys in the past so
West Virginia you got an athletic
linebacker or somebody who does you know
have some range they're drafted us for
Ross Pierce bakker West Martin Brice
love Terry Maclaurin Montez sweat Dwayne
Haskins so they've done a very very good
job addressing needs so I think that's
the key here talent yeah with talent
didn't have not reached no Wes Martin
might have been the only one but again
if you drafted him and Pierce Walker
flipped those we would have been good
yeah do I remind you guys grades for all
32 teams classes will be in the Bleacher
Report app stick to football comes out
every Monday Wednesday Friday morning
you can get that in your be our app you
can subscribe on Apple podcast stitcher
Spotify
wherever you get your shows but download
the Bleacher Report app subscribe to
that stick to football stream and you
will never miss a thing you'll get our
tweet you'll get our show schedule any
videos that we're doing any ranking so
the be our app is definitely the best
place to hang out with the stick to
football crew waiting for this last pic
to come in guys and then we'll get into
2020 2020 very excited for that Barbara
Walters yeah it's a good class man yeah
she could grade some of those dudes it's
gonna be
easy scouting for next year so
Washington a good draft support which is
a nice rebound for them you know we
really have it always like oh we'll
they'll get a guy from Alabama like John
Allen or drama pain that's a good pick
and I like Gary's guys last year
unfortunately he got hurt so it seems
like they've they have done a good job
of addressing needs with like you said
Connor like big named good players here
let's see what they do here so Cole
Holcomb linebacker from North Carolina
the final pick in round five yeah a
little bit of a surprise I had a backup
grade on him 6 foot 1 231 pounds guys a
little bit small but really productive a
former walk-on and North Carolina so
maybe they're going with a little bit of
a character pick here at around 5 could
play some special teams in for forced
fumbles actually has a senior so good
production speed is their run and chase
type linebacker for the Redskins to
close out around 5 yes still would have
preferred David long in that spot but
yeah we're I think there are a lot I'm
scrolling through linebackers here that
are still on the board but overall the
Redskins have a very good draft so if
you want to grab a linebacker like that
high character got a good Shrine game
good trying game now guys my favorite
part of every draft class is when we
move on to next year scrap draft class I
will have a mock draft coming out Monday
morning and a lot of these names are
gonna be up there this is my 2020 top-10
chase young Oh weird Ohio State's got
another amazing pass rusher who's gonna
start the a top on the board Walker
little offensive tackle from Stanford
look at the receivers though guys
Jerry Judy T Higgins Levesque Ashan all
studs and yes to it is my third
quarterback heading into next year I'm
taking Jake from State from as QB one
next year smart quarterback accurate and
grand elf it's just a stud I love Grand
Elvin a lot of people have questions
with the Jake from fingers yeah it
disagreed they say that he doesn't have
the tool of the arm string
he's gonna be in my top ten - I like
from a guy I went to highlight those
Walker little and you see him on the big
boy big board number - wow that looks
weird Matt it's very similar to yours
but I finished my first wall a second
here well I really like his game six
foot seven 312 pounds out of Stanford
he's at
this guy if he can anchor in the lower
half of his body he's gonna be one of
the best tackle prospects we've seen in
a very long time and also you go lower
down this board there's also a tackle
out of Georgia Thomas Brown I believe is
his name great tackle prospects coming
in and next year receivers running backs
quarterbacks a lot of talent in 2020 I'm
very excited to be working on it next
year Delp it might be the best overall
player in the country
honestly he's that kind of thing he fits
for Heisman again next year you know I'm
driving that train all the way all right
do you want to throw up a grade for melo
before we get out here yeah let's do it
Melo I mean I like you but now I'm just
gonna see - now Melo gets an 8 right
great happen there we go yeah yeah so I
don't want to make another Miller just
be humble bragging for the rest of the
podcast so I'm still giving them an a
though except yeah we got to set the bar
low come back maybe you come back next
year more Michael Jackson reference guys
will have me I'm not good yeah all right
that is our show for today get in that
be our app Connor and I will be in there
getting yeah look at look at this hair
the hair will be in there we'll be
breaking down every team's draft for you
and don't forget Monday morning stick to
football is back we'll be taking every
team's draft putting it under the
microscope for Melamed Connor I'm Matt
thanks for hanging out with this
stickies we love you stick football fan
we love you we'll see you guys real soon
[Music]
[Music]